good evening everybody this is a meeting
of the planning and development
management Committee of traffic Council
my name is councilor Ben Hartley I'm the
chair of the committee for the meeting
on my immediate right is councilor Barry
Wynn Stanley who is the vice chair of
the committee uh on my on my left and
further on my right are offices from the
council's planning team legal team and
highways team and then along the tables
uh to the side are members of the
committee and I will introduce those
members by uh by name when they wish to
speak they are local councilors for
everybody's information this meeting is
being filmed and broadcast on the
council's YouTube channel so it's
available to to view live and the
recordings are also available to view
for a Time afterwards
um
we'll
cancel you and can I just check are you
able to hear us okay
I I didn't catch
it I'm sorry okay we're just starting
the meeting so we haven't started with
the item that you're here for yet but as
look as long as you can hear what's
being said
um I can hear most
ly not all of it
okay let's let's see how we are when we
get to the item that that you're here
for
um thank you
we'll start the agenda with item number
one which is attendances and any
apologies for absence I've not had any
apologies for absence except that I know
that uh councilor bunting is stuck in
traffic so he's likely to be late
but I think everybody else is is here
and present so there's no apologies
thank you item number two is membership
and the committee is asked to note that
councilor Freeman became a member of the
committee as of 24th of October 2022
replacing councilor dagner so councilor
Freeman's here uh welcome councilor
Freeman
um item number three is Declarations of
Interest so members are to give notice
of any personal or prejudicial interest
and the nature of that interest relating
to any item on the agenda in accordance
with the adopted code of conduct
counselor chalkin
uh thank you uh just uh no it's that
I'll be stepping out the gebo
application
um because I'm prejudiced against that
okay thank you and counselor Freeman um
the example more infants application
that uh premises is within my award
however
as a council I've had no um contact with
any residents or anyone about the
application therefore oh we're not very
accusing myself from that item thank you
thank you councilor Freeman for that
clarification item number four is the
minutes of the last meeting so it's to
receive uh and if so determined to
approve as a correct record the minutes
of the meeting held on the 13th of
October 2022 uh councilor Thomas you're
happy to make those minutes uh and I'm
happy to second that they're an accurate
record so we will accept those minutes
as an accurate record of the last
meeting
item number five is questions from
members of the public so this is an item
with a maximum of 15 minutes to be
allocated to public questions submitted
in writing to democratic Services by 4
pm on a working day prior to this
meeting uh questions must be within the
remit of the committee or be relevant to
items which appear on the agenda and
will be submitted in the order they were
received and I understand we've had no
no questions for this meeting
item number six is the additional
information report so it's to consider a
report from the head of Planning and
Development which has been tabled at the
meeting so copies should be available
for members and they were a copy was
also emailed out earlier today so we
will take account of the information
uh in that report as we come to each of
the applications we're considering
[Music]
welcome councilor bunting we've started
the agenda we're just about to come on
to the application so you've arrived at
a good time apologies for my latest uh
chairman Blaine Manchester United
okay thank you item number seven is
applications for permission to develop
Just for information on each of the
applications that we'll consider we'll
start with a an introduction from a
member of the planning team and that
will usually involve a presentation
which will appear on the screen uh
behind me
um when we've had that presentation we
may then have speakers both against and
for an item so we'll then hear from
those speakers uh we have some Ward
counselors attending tonight to speak on
items as well so Ward councilors will
have a maximum of five minutes to speak
to us and the other speakers will have a
maximum of three minutes to speak to us
and if you're running up to that time
then I will ask you to conclude your
remarks
once we've heard from those speakers we
will then open up the debate to members
of the committee and I'll introduce
people by name when they wish to speak
on each of the applications we will uh
we will vote on the application we may
have a number of votes and I'll explain
those if we do and the vote will be a
buy a show of hands
um can I also say that once we've heard
from uh Ward councilors and other
speakers members of the committee cannot
then engage in debate with speakers so
there won't be any opportunity for for
question and answer with with speakers
um who who've already addressed us so
um
with that in mind I think that's
everything I need to say about our
introduction we'll move on to the first
application that we will consider
tonight which is uh chibo uh in hail
Victoria Road in Hale uh councilor chalk
and I'm just uh noting for the record
that you're leaving is advised so for
members of the uh committee that starts
on uh page 84 I think of the bundle that
we've got and we're going to start with
an introduction from Miss Coley thank
you
thank you chairman
this full planning application seeks
retrospective planning permission for
the creation of an external roof Terrace
to the front elevation forming an
extended dining area of the restaurant
the roof Terrace comprises of a 3.44
meter high glazed canopy with steel
framework and a 1.1 meter high glass
balustrade around the perimeter of the
resulting roof Terrace
access to the roof Terrace has been
created through the replacement of three
existing Timber sash windows with
aluminum patio doors at first floor
level
all other first raw Timber sash windows
to the front elevation have also been
replaced with aluminum windows now this
latter point about the windows is late
information which is included in your
additional information report if members
could could make reference to that
because there is quite a lot of
additional information on on this item
and you'll notice also that one of the
reasons for refusal has been updated
accordingly
um in respect of that late information
the roof canopy structure has been
decorated with Driftwood style Timber
moss and artificial leaves and flowers
the application site is located just
within the boundary of hail village with
listen Grove lying outside of the
Village Center boundary and is located
within the Hale station Conservation
Area the building is classified as a
positive contributor and a landmark
building within the hail station
Conservation Area appraisal and forms
part of a key view in the conservation
area the site is also located within the
setting of the grade 2 listed hail
station buildings which lie on the
western side of Victoria Road the
surrounding areas mixed in character
with commercial properties on Victoria
Road and Residential Properties on
listen Grove
representation supporting the proposals
have been received from neighboring
residents and also residents outside of
Trafford the applicant has submitted two
petitions in support of the proposals
which because they have not been
submitted directly to the council by
those in support and furthermore do not
provide the address of petitioners can
only be afforded limited weight
letters of support have also been
received from councilor Mrs Young and
the Hale Civic Society two letters of
objection have been received from
residents of hail
the site has extant planning permission
for the creation of a roof Terrace above
the existing single-story route to the
front elevation including the erection
of a 1.1 meter high glass balustrade
which will be situated behind a planting
bed ranging between 0.64 meters and 0.93
meters deep the application also
approved the replacement of an existing
window with patio doors
following the grouting of this consent a
roof Terrace was erected on the site in
April 2022 which did not comply with the
approved plans of the extant consent the
resulting roof Terrace is now the
subject of this planning application
the applicant argues that the
development is required to secure the
viability of the existing business and
that should planning permission be
refused he would have to close the
restaurant due to the current economic
climate would not be able to sell the
property for a number of years and so it
would remain vacant no substantive
evidence has been submitted to support
this argument although the applicant has
been invited to do so the proposal is
considered to appear unduly prominent
and significantly obscure the upper
level of the building and therefore
detract from the ascetic and historic
significance of the building and its
contribution to the Conservation Area
The Proposal would result in less than
substantial harm in mppf terms it is
considered that there is no clear and
convincing justification for this harm
which has not been minimized the extant
permission for the roof Terrace was
considered to strike an appropriate
balance between the impact on Heritage
assets and the needs of the business
there are no Heritage benefits arising
from the proposals
regardless of the identified Heritage
harm the proposals are also considered
to represent poor design
members should be mindful that in
planning terms any consideration of
viability should be based of the on the
viability of the building as a
restaurant or other commercial use not
the applicant's own business model
members must satisfy themselves as
another business could not reasonably
operate successfully from the premises
if this application were to be refused
equally any subsequent harm arising from
a vacant unit should be assessed in
terms of its impact on the vitality and
viability of hail District Center as a
whole
the planning system is not concerned
with the competition between businesses
or the success or failure of individual
businesses these are private interests
rather than the public interest
otherwise this is an argument that could
be repeated too often that a business
will close if planning permission is not
granted but otherwise unacceptable
development
considerable importance of weight has
been given to the desirability of
preserving the hail station Conservation
Area and the character of this Landmark
positive contributed within it the
applicant has failed to identify public
benefits of the proposals that would
outweigh the less than substantial harm
identified which it is considered to be
in the moderate range of less than
substantial
The Proposal will be contrary to the
development plan and the relevant
Conservation Area appraisal and
management plan
the application of policies in the
framework that protect areas or assets
of particular importance provide a clear
reason for refusing the development
proposed it is therefore recommended
that the application is refused thank
you
thank you Miss Coley is Mr Franks with
us
hello Mr Frank do you want to come and
have a seat at the at the chair opposite
me
um and you're here to speak against the
application
um as I mentioned earlier you'll have
three minutes so we'll start the timer
once you start speaking and if you come
up to three minutes I'll just ask you to
conclude your marks yeah and if you
press the button it should like yeah
there you go so you're all set so
whenever you're ready um good evening
I'm Patrick Franks here to speak against
the retrospective application for the
unauthorized works at sibo Hale I'm a
local resident and a local business
owner within Hale Village firstly I'd
state that I'm neither against the
applicant or the principal of the roof
Terrace of the property but
environmentally against the Insidious
creep of unauthorized works at the
property that have cumulatively created
the unfathomable mess that you see
before you is a retrospective
application for Works yet the
information presented is so far from
what is built that I would suggest the
application is not actually determinable
and approval would be not be for what is
built and a refusal would also not be
relevant to what is built I would asked
the legal officers further to advise on
the implications of a vote on
information that is materially different
from what is built
you will be aware of a large number of
letters of support but these seem to be
based on the quality of food and service
of the applicant these are not planning
issues and it should be understood that
planning is in perpetuity and thus the
current unauthorized and inappropriately
designed terrorists could at any time in
the future be operated by Hooters or any
other operator who wants to take over
you may be tempted to offer a sympathy
vote to the applicant due to the amount
of money they have obviously expended
but you should be wary of this there are
two possible scenarios here either the
applicant is disrespecting this
committee and has knowingly submitted a
misleading application in the belief
that the committee don't have the
expertise or intelligence to understand
drawings or is professional team are so
poor and negligent that they should be
liable for letting him down and should
be sued the applicant is at the last
minute submitted details of numerous
entry or soon-to-empty shops in the
village this only heightens the
importance that the committee listens to
their officers and backs up their
carefully considered report that
highlights the currently unacceptable
scheme
if this application were approved it
would only encourage the application for
the 11 units cited by the applicant to
just do what they want and put in
inappropriate post
um Works applications this will
inevitably lead the village to be poorer
for all you to consider in this
important location the applicant has
ripped out Timber sash windows installed
aluminum bifold after getting permission
for Timber half glazed ones installed a
gas glass balustrade substantially away
from where it is shown on the drawings
thus increasing the area of the Terrace
further than they are actually still
seeking permission for they've enclosed
the Terrace while not putting this on
the drawings they've built over the
adjoining property and perhaps most
significantly of clad the entire ground
floor of the property and the original
cornice and detail of the building in
aluminum while asking on their approved
drawings for pharaoh and ball paint I
believe there is an acceptable solution
out there that will serve the
applicant's purported needs but they
would need to accept that they have
behaved badly unlawfully and
disrespectfully to this committee and
work with officers and others to deliver
a scheme that was set a positive example
for other future applications and
schemes to come thank you thank chemist
Franks if you'd just like to return to
your seat uh councilor young I don't do
you want to speak to us first I'll do
okay Mr valboni if you'd like to come
and take a seat uh opposite me
and
as for the last speaker you'll have um
three minutes to speak to us and we'll
start the clock
um once you start speaking so whenever
you're ready thank you
thank you Mr chairman Mr Hartley um
Chief planning officer Mrs uh Coley
members of the committee and members of
staff
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak and allow me this space to
apologize in person to all of you for
putting you in such a difficult position
I am fully aware and take full
responsibility for my action and I'd
like to ensure you that the action I
took are regrettable
I'd like to also emphasize that they
were done at least as a last resort in
order to save the business this meant we
could continue operating and keep our 67
colleagues 67 colleagues in jobs who
most of them are local residents when we
first moved to hail we believed we would
be successful despite two previous
restaurants having failed at this side
Although our original operation was
popular
our business began to suffer because the
limits of the
existing Curves in the building we then
had the opportunity to purchase the
building so we could expand onto the
first floor and create the roof Terrace
in order to maximize the covers which we
did making us committed members inhale
unfortunately same as all businesses we
were also affected by the pandemic but
because of the commitments we have
managed to retain all jobs
now we are operation
our operation continues to be affected
by energy and food cost crisis meaning
furthermore barriers
the many cons many consultations with
our accountant in order to retain jobs I
was presented with three Avenues to
double the prices close the business or
increase covers
Dublin the prices would not work despite
hail being a wealthy area charging 40
pound per bottle of pasta would be
unacceptable and unstainable this would
simply have resulted in closing the
business anyway increasing the cover
seems to be the only possible option and
that's why I had to make the decision to
increase covers in order for the
business to survive
we work closely with residents and
locals I would like to to point out that
our business offers many opportunities
to the of Employments to the young
residents of hail many young people from
the village have been trained and worked
particularly during the half term and
after school or college
I'll try to give this background
information because if we can't provide
the number of spaces created by our
Terrace we'd unfortunately have to close
this would mean 67 families without jobs
many young people without opportunities
of employment
the village is already weakening as many
restaurants recently closed hopefully
this also explained why we took action
to ensure that we could contribute
positively to strength of the village
support locals residents and retain our
colleagues jobs
we respect officers views but we want to
assure you that everything has been done
in cooperation with neighbors residents
and businesses which they confirmed
through their representations that they
consider the terrorists to be welcomed
well-designed and complementary addition
to the village and Conservation Area
we just want to finish your remarks if
you could thank you if you just finish
the point you're on and then and then
we'll stop there thank you the terror
structure is not permanently attached to
the building and we can enter into a
planning obligation requiring us to
remove if we have ever to go
thank you for coming and dressing as Mr
valboni
um
counselor do you want to stay where you
are yeah of course yeah yes of course so
you'll you'll have uh five minutes to
speak to us and we'll start a timer
whenever you're ready thank you yes
thank you
Tebow is on a site that has previously
been occupied by two organizations
namely carluccio and the American Bar
and Grill both these restaurants
struggled to run a profitable concern on
the existing site as the chibo before
the shutdown period
during the shutdown chibo retained all
of their 67 staff and took the decision
then that an extended Terrace would be
needed if the restaurant was to be
economically successful
off to shut down work was started
without planning permission as they
wished to commence trading again as soon
as possible
the extension took some six weeks to
complete whilst we all know that it can
take well over three to six months to
get planning permission as the planning
office is always extremely busy
the basic building is not it's not
distinctive and does not have any
specific historical significance it's a
forgettable ordinary normal building
with no special features
nevertheless when the alteration was
planned care was taken to ensure that
the actual building was not damaged in
any way and this was
in in any way the canopy was erected
after consultation with a structural
engineer who supervised the build and it
can be removed at any time restoring the
building to its untouched original in
the way that the stage set is removed at
the end of an act
the conservation of the building is
assured it will no longer be visible but
it will be undamaged
hail Conservation Area is a vital and
viable one which does not highlight the
fact that there have been an alarming
number of recent business failures some
nine establishments including four
restaurants have closed or indicated
their intention to close I don't think
officers understand the actual concerns
of hail counselors hail residents and
the hail business Community we need to
revitalize hail Village and encourage
people to come to hail which is why it
is so important that business
organizations are supported
if we prevent this development chibo
will have to close an up to 70 local
people will lose their jobs we will be
left with an empty shell of a boarded-up
building dragging or already declining
Center further down I don't believe we
we will be fulfilling our civic duty if
we prevent unnecessary development that
residents like and support indeed
residents have commented on how well the
terrorist is designed and that it is a
high quality addition to the
Conservation Area
since Jibo opened I have not had any
complaints regarding nuisance or Noise
by their immediate neighbors and I wish
I could say the same about some of the
other catering establishments in Yale
management consults with their neighbors
before any alterations or changes that
could affect them are made
they have been about 60 representations
of support received from people in hail
six from immediate neighbors and only
one I believe it is now two objections
a petition of a hundred representations
has also been provided I've been dealing
with planning applications for many
years now and I have never known such a
large number of people writing to
support an application usually the only
letters we receive are objections
why do we hold consultations on planning
applications if we don't take note of
What the residents wish
my opinion there's a local councilor
living within walking distance of the
center of hail is that we need
successful organizations such as Jibo to
open and to succeed to encourage more
members of the public to come into hail
and hopefully to revitalize this small
business Community
please would you
decide to approve this application thank
you
[Music]
thank you councilor young
um so I'll come to the committee in a
moment I'm just going to ask uh Miss
curly and possibly also our legal
officer for
um some advice on well two things really
one was the point raised by Mr Franks
which was around in in in his submission
some of the information we have being
misleading and whether we should go
ahead and determine the application
nonetheless and then the other point
which was um just mentioned by councilor
Jung is obviously we've got a high
number of
um letters of support or people who've
signed a petition and what sort of
weight that should have with the
committee in planning terms thank you
um thank you chairman I'll I'll take
those in turn
um the first query is about the accuracy
of the submitted plans and indeed the
plans have been amended uh on a number
of occasions throughout the process to
to get them to more accurately reflect
what has actually been built on site
um nevertheless members are making a
decision on on those plans
um and
um depending on what members are minded
to do this evening determination is
possible in the if members are managed
to go with the office of recommendation
and refuse the application and then they
would be refusing the development on the
plans
um
because it it may be slightly inaccurate
but it's not miles off however
um the step up after that would be an
enforcement notice if that was necessary
that
um enforcement notice could be based on
an accurate and up-to-date survey that
was taken at the time of serving that
notice so so we would have another
opportunity to actually enforce again
what what was there so I don't think
there's any any reason members couldn't
um refuse the application this evening
in terms of an approval
um if there are further inaccuracies
then of course officers can check that
and if members uh were so minded they
could defer and delegate that decision
to me to get a set of accurate drawings
which we were all satisfied represented
what was on site and then issue that
decision under delegated powers
obviously if members are managed to
approve uh officers would need to come
up with an appropriate set of conditions
in any event so so there's no reason why
we couldn't do both both of those things
um coming to the issue of the weight to
be given to representations
um I've obviously um the weight of any
material consideration the planning
decision is is for the decision maker
um however in terms of petitions that
are submitted to to
um to the council
um greater weight should generally be
given to representations that come
directly to the council from those who
are making those representations because
um it shows that they have a it's very
easy to sign a piece of paper that's
given to you it's less easy to actually
take the time and actually write into
the council so officers will always give
less weight to petitions which are
submitted by by applicants
um but of course that the actual weight
to be given to it is a matter entirely
for you this evening members
[Music]
thank you
um so I'll look now to members that are
committed to start the debate uh
councilor button I'll start with you
[Music]
thank you chairman
um
this was an interesting one remember I
first read the report before going to do
my site visit and perhaps that's another
point that maybe won the few despite Mrs
Cody's very detailed response where one
of the few things that she didn't
mention is that obviously we have done
site visits so except that there may be
some issues regarding the plans but this
is a retrospective application I've been
there and looked at it myself so I can
see exactly what it is I'm not wholly
Reliant upon upon plans I have been uh
to the site as I'm sure other members of
the committee will have done also so
um but when I did with this report
initially at home I thought oh my
goodness it sounds pretty pretty
terrible
and I was I have to say when I got there
and had a look at it and pleasantly
surprised I know my love of modern
architecture is legendary on this
committee
um uh yeah thank you and um and I and
I've often disagreed with officers uh or
agreed to them over conservation and
disagree with people saying oh this
modern building will fit beautifully
into this area but on this occasion I
have to admit
I think councilor Mrs Young and the uh
applicants have got a good point to make
I don't think that this despoils the
area I think it does interestingly fit
in relatively well uh to to this area I
don't think the design is the
catastrophic mess that the uh that the
objector made it out to be
and uh I I think there are a lot of
positives towards it yes nobody wants to
see
um a business go out to uh go you know
fail and a building to be left empty
though yeah it's it can often start a
domino like effect as one after another
goes and you can see areas start to fail
as more and more buildings close and one
several have gone it gets more and more
difficult to stop so there is a there is
a general public good in preventing in
in preventing that where reason where we
can uh reasonably do so I'm not
suggesting we should disregard rules at
all but of course there's a considerable
degree of discretion involved that's the
whole point of having this committee if
it was just a case of you know going by
rules exactly what he said well then you
could abolish planning committee
tomorrow and never bother with it again
the whole point of having this here is
that that is that we take that uh that
uh that uh discretion use that
discretion that's the reason why
applications are referred to this
referred to this committee
um I do think as I say that the building
fits in in well within the area I was
pleasantly surprised by the design and I
don't think it's going to have any
material harm on the conservation of
that area if uh as has been pointed out
the building itself is relatively
insignificant in terms of the actual
architectural merits of it there's
nothing wrong with it but it's not
exactly a thing of beauty that you go
and stand on the opposite side of the
road and admire and I don't think that
this structure doesn't need harm to it
either so it could if necessary be
removed otherwise I wouldn't I I see
nothing wrong with what's there so I'm
I'm going to respectfully disagree with
the officers I am taking into account
and just to address that point that you
made also Mrs Cooley I take a great deal
of importance interviews and opinions of
local people and I also pay a great deal
of attention to local councilors that's
what they're there for the counselors
are there to represent that area and
this is a Mrs Young was often complained
in the past when I never agree with her
well on this occasion I am agreeing with
her and I'm more than happy chairman to
propose that we
Grant in in contrary to the uh officer
recommendation
um the simple reason being that I cannot
agree with the two uh reasons for
refusal that are given on page 111. uh
thank you chairman thank you councilor
Brunson councilor Welton
oh it's just a quick question on the
bifold doors and the new information
about those I presume bifold doors
aren't they aren't an original feature
of the the property are they no no okay
thank you
counselor Freeman
thank you chair um I don't like
applications retrospective I never have
done
um but I have to say that um like
councilor bunting I visited these
premises
um and I spent a whole hour stood
outside I've actually been into the
premises and I've been onto that Terrace
as well
and what better way of judging whether
it's suitable for the area than to
actually take a poll of people walking
past on a Sunday morning couples who
live in the village
um and who who walk past it
and I actually spoke to over five
different couples who live locally and I
asked them the same question if they
believed that the terrorists detracts
from the historical characteristics of
the building and significant and
significant plays in The Heritage area
and they looked at me quite blankly and
thought what are you talking about
um and all of them viewed the terrorists
positively and so he's added something
to that area and as I looked around I
then looked across the Heritage area and
there we've got the very ugly Cheshire
Midland boarded up
a pub that's gone
um and so I have sympathy with what um
councilor young has been saying I asked
a further question of people I said well
can you recall what the building looked
like before this Terrace went up
and none of these five couples could and
when I looked at the building myself at
the side
I actually do think some of the
brickwork on it is 1950s I can't see
what the historical value or is of that
building
absolutely what I do see is is something
that you can only see as you come around
the corner past the station and it's a
balcony that is
quite attractive
and I spent a whole hour musing in that
area and and I've struggled to to see
what the uh where the damage this
building actually does to to the
Heritage area
um and it's not very often that I agree
with councilor bunting or anything but
on this occasion I I have to say I do
agree with it and I have a lot of
Sympathy For What Council young has said
um and and um but I don't like the fact
it's a retrospect about because you do
wish people when they want to do things
would do it by the book but on this
occasion I have to say that I would
support the proposal that councilor
bunting has put before us
thank you Council Freeman councilor win
Stanley uh thank you chair uh this would
be great interest on my two colleagues
said before me
um but I disagree with their conclusion
I went up
yeah is that bad
[Music]
better
[Music]
um
came to a different conclusion I don't
object to the design of the building I
think as a as a modern restaurant the
designers is really good it's in the
wrong place and it's not just the damage
um to the Heritage asset of the building
itself it's the Heritage it's the damage
to the Heritage asset of the whole area
so if you stand on it's actually Road I
think isn't it that goes to the center
of hail it's down from there look back
towards the station The View towards the
station is it really is impeached upon
by the uh by the roof Terrace and with
the uh the roof over there I have great
sympathy with the business owner I
really do I also agree sympathy with the
um uh with the the residents and
business owner who spoke against this
I think Ryan at the moment is I'm
inclined to vote in line with officer
recommendation and refuse the planning
permission a final point I also don't
like retro retrospective planning
permission I know it's not strictly
relevant to the
decision we make but
uh the business owners who bought the
building must have predicated a business
plan on certain things and it would have
been wise to get the planning permission
before you went ahead and
um did did what you did at the moment
I'm I'm inclined to vote against this
thank you chair thank you again so much
I'm the councilor Proctor
chair
I hate retroactive planning applications
um to me it's the especially when what's
been built there's no resemblance to an
existing planning planning application
that's been approved it makes a nonsense
of this committee and the decisions we
make as a committee
they haven't just
built it bigger they've destroyed what
was there
by taking the wooden windows out and
replacing them with aluminum
there's reasons why
we stipulate what has to be replaced and
they've clearly completely gone against
what was stipulated in the planning
application that was approved
so I cannot support this retroactive
planning application whatsoever it's
what they've done is
it's strong it's made a nonsense of of
the work we put in thank you
thank you cancer Proctor councilor Walsh
see you next thank you
thanks chair
um
I've come to this with a very open mind
and I was very interested in what
councilman bunting in councilor Freeman
says but
I think I'm going to go against uh what
the two colleagues have said
um
the applicant knew what was proposed and
what had been agreed for this
application and he did go against that
um I know Mrs Young said planning can
take three to six months I think
sometimes it can take a lot longer than
that
um but the applicant was aware of what
was uh if I can say it simply allowed at
this site what could be built above
there and it certainly wasn't the
application that we see before us this
evening
um we do get retrospective planning
applications and I I'm I'm comfortable
with people uh if you like challenging
the committee and and disagreeing with
them that's fine but this is a
conservation area and the reasons that
we the planning officers advise the
applicant around what was uh reasonable
at this location was to preserve that
that Conservation Area and I would
suggest that one of the reasons the
restaurant is successful
is that it is in that Conservation Area
it's a very attractive
part of the borough and one that I want
to protect and I'm sure lots of all the
members on the planning committee do I'm
very uncomfortable with going against
things that damage the conservation area
and it does destroy the look of that
building
when you view if you look at that
drawing now you cannot see those wooden
sash windows they are gone
and uh and then and then I may say that
and I would say the people challenging
the committee that is fine uh members
have talked about well members of the
public are quite happy
I asked this chap in the street and he
said what are you talking about well if
we our Council the bunsenal that all the
applications that we we gave we are we
talk to the man in the street I'm sure
they would I'll have stronger stronger
and different views to ourselves but we
have got to go on planning guidelines
we've got to go on planning laws and
they're not uh to be taken lightly
um I'm disappointed that we're in this
situation and the feel for the applicant
the last thing uh this Council wants is
to put a business
um in trouble into difficulty I do not
want that to happen
but I can't support this application
because it damages the conservation here
something that we've got to be protected
and what makes hail I would argue so
special so I'll be supporting the
officer's recommendations to refuse this
thank you
thank you councilor Walsh councilor
Thomas
thank you chair
um I'm in Broad agreement with what
council Walton
councilman Stanley Council Proctor uh
have said we wouldn't be sat here if the
roof Terrace that received planning
permission for 30 covers were built as
per application
103732 we just wouldn't be here and the
drawings in the documents have been sent
regarding what was approved and what is
now
uh are so vastly different you have to
query whether or not at this time
of the original approval of
103732 whether they if the application
had been for what is proposed tonight
whether that would have been passed
we would not be here if the designer of
the Terrace had stuck to the original
planning permission
we I fell fall of Miss being misusing
planning guidance shall we say a number
of occasions and I've been put right and
rightly so we have planning guidance
that we have to follow this does not
follow planning guidance and I will be
supporting the office's recommendation
thank you counselor Thomas councilor
Morgan
thank you chair um
I was originally going to be
um supporting officers on this but I
have to be honest cancer Bunting and
cancer Freeman persuaded me um on this
and and I
you do you do you you you you do you
look at the reasons to reviews and I I
just don't agree with them I do actually
think it is a really good design and
it's
I I hate the retrospective nature of it
as other members of of said
um and this is a substantial
change but fundamentally the reasons to
refuse I don't actually agree I do
actually don't think it's a um it's
harmful to the hailstation conservation
area
um I don't think it's in sympathetic so
um a feeling I might be a minority on it
but um I will be supporting councilman
and Council Freeman in supporting this
application against office of
recommendations thank you
thank you councilor Morgan any other
members looking to speak on this item
before we come to vote so
um oh sorry cancel a minute
I guess it's a bit it's more of a
question so I know that they've I mean
my my qualm with it is the removal of
the wooden windows
um and how in terms of it being
obviously a conservation area and how
much of a problem is the removal of the
windows I went to have a look at and I
can't remember what the old windows you
know I can only see what's there now I
know that they're obviously the new the
new ones are gray as well but I'm trying
to yeah if I don't know if it's a way of
that's what it was like
okay
and then can we see it with it I mean I
know it's got a it's got the roof part
the sort of thing that you can't see the
windows can you
because gold Greenery around it you
can't
see it very well can you yeah and
unfortunately as we only found found out
about this on the plans today we haven't
focused on that in in a photograph yeah
no no but it but it is certainly Inc in
office's view increases the harm quite
quite considerably so that the removal
of the wooden window is is okay okay
that's that's what my question was thank
you
thank you councilor wealth and can we
condition if we were to approve this can
we condition the change of material on
the Windows is that
it's possible
it not not really we need to serve an
enforcement notice specifically for that
and it will be kind of a part approval
part refusal I I think that would be
legally very tricky to do
any other members looking to speak
no
oh do you want to spit okay cancel
yeah my reluctance to speak is because I
am completely split on this it is so
tough I mean you can look at it two ways
it's a really it's a really tough one in
a sense for a planning committee member
it's like a win-win situation if you
vote you know if you vote to to refuse
it then you are you're basically you you
you're sticking up for planning rules if
you vote to approve it you're sticking
up to a love for to a to a large extent
for for local opinion a successful
business and uh you know and one that
people are you know appreciating and I
really you know and the trouble is we
don't know where we where we would be
after this we can't take that into
account personally you know I guess to a
certain extent has to come down to at
the end of the day when one is split
like this it has to it has to come down
to what one thinks about it personally
and I think personally really like it so
I'm finding it very difficult to you
know to find it's similar to uh uh
councilor Morgan I'm finding difficult
to match the response and I did I mean I
spoke to a local architect the other the
other day
um you know
uh
I know about about it and
you know not not related and who's not
related to the scheme in any way and he
said well the problem is is we can't
propose things like this because we know
that they'll get rejected because of the
uh
um because of you know no matter how
successful they might be in in in the
reality because of because of the
constraints of the conservation area and
of course this means that we might end
up you know we end up putting things in
aspect
um you know and uh and ending up with a
with an area that just can't change as
it needs to change and for me that's
problematic thank you
thank you uh councilor akinola
I too have some difficulties with um
this I haven't looked at it my first
view was that I thought it looked fine
but I really do have concerns about
people going against planning and not
doing what is right within a
conservation area and I find it really
difficult
um to approve something that there was
plans made and they've been totally
disregarded
um and I do worry that if we do allow
um
applications to just go ahead and do
what they want to do will be innocent
what do we do in a situation where we
don't like the look of it just because
this one looks alright
what about the next one when it looks
horrific
thank you Council Okinawa
um
councilor Freeman you wanted to to speak
again so I know you uh spoke in favor of
granting the application you just just
to point out the council Welton that um
if you look at the applicant submission
um a condition could be imposed required
in the refer to return to its original
state if sibo would to vacate the
premises that might help you in your
decision
so you know we could conduct they're
inviting a condition
on themselves to return it to each state
if they were to vacate those premises
cancer um Council Freeman were you I
think councilor bunting prepares that we
Grant planning permission are you happy
to second that first one thank you okay
thank you Council for free mate uh uh
councilor Winston that you wanted to
come in yeah
thank you
um I started off the debate by saying my
instinct was to if I was against this
um and I think my instinct remains there
after listening to the debate to your
point uh uh councilor Welton we're not
setting the conservation area in aspect
we're not there was Planet permission
granted for a change to this building
but the plans the plans have not been
followed by the applicant so I have to
listen to debates I'm now happy to
propose that we refuse the application
in line with officer recommendation
thank you chair
thank you um councilor bunting you
wanted to come in again just just to
make one point
if I go one one everybody would agree
with Council Thomas absolutely yes if he
built what was their planned originally
then we wouldn't be discussing tonight
absolutely right you wouldn't because
there'll be no point the whole point of
us discussing tonight is that he's done
something different but there is no rule
against submitting a retrospective
application to regularize something that
you have done that's not illegal and you
I know a lot of people around the room
have said oh I really don't like
retrospective applications well
retrospective applications exist and
we're supposed to deal with them as I
have hopefully this evening in exactly
the same way as you would any other
application you judge it based on the
facts of what is planned and what is
being put there you can't sell while
it's better perspective application
therefore you know uh no chance uh but
that's not what we're able to do and yes
I accept that there are aspects of this
design that you might not like for
example windows and what have you but
then again as has also been pointed out
on some applications you can't even see
the windows
um so how much of an impact did that
having the conservation area if you
can't even see them so uh it's a yes
it's a negative but it's not an
insurmountable negative and yes I accept
there are planning guidance but that's
exactly what they are guidance they are
not there it's a straight jacket and to
prevent decision making as I say if it
was the case it was simply a case of
reading the rules out of a book and
getting your technology and saying this
has done there'd be no point in any of
us being here this evening or indeed on
any other planning committee meeting
because there wouldn't be a planning
committee to have in the first place
thank you Jeff okay thank you Council
building so I mean there isn't there
isn't anything wrong with somebody
submitting a retrospective planning
application I think we're we're clear on
that but I guess
um I guess if if an applicant does that
they run the risk that it will be
refused after they've built something
and that's the position here I think
um
so chairman I was simply saying the
argument that people have several times
are only just for public record that
people said well I really don't like
without we just deal with them in the
neutral matter we're not supposed to be
holding it against them the fact that I
accept absolutely tell me what you're
saying that we have the right to refuse
them and obviously that could then lead
to enforcement and removal of that which
you've built exactly absolutely that was
simply that point I was making okay
thank you Al uh Miss Carly wanted to
give some advice on a couple of points I
think thank you thank you thank you
chairman I mean members will be aware
that
um applications in conservation areas
and Heritage assets are very easy to go
wrong in loron so um I just if I could
just like to clarify a couple of points
that that may
um may not influence whether members
think they should be approved or refused
but may influence how how you get there
um the
um the first thing is to say is that the
the screening the plants and the and the
tin well the artificial
um Greenery that's not development that
could come down at any time that serves
to
um mask this the um steel structure and
it says to mask the change in Windows
um but members should consider the the
development without that uh because that
isn't that is decoration
um so you should consider it the steel
structure alone
the other point is that in in um
considering Heritage applications you
have to consider whether there is a
clear and convincing justification for
the proposals and that harm has been
minimized so can the sort of effect are
you the roof Terrace with with some
shelter come about
um in any less harmful way and the
windows have been mentioned for example
um and officers obviously think that the
steel frame is is extremely harmful
members may have a different view on
that but that's fine
um the other thing two pointers I've
heard a couple of members say that they
don't think the building is of any
historic importance you cannot disregard
the advice of the conservation area
appraisal and set that aside that is
professional advice on a Heritage asset
it is completely completely within your
remit to say you don't think there is
harm
but you would would likely be erring in
law if you just set aside what the
conservation area appraisal says about
the significance of the building because
um you you you can't do that
um so um just those points of
clarification which members which might
wish to come along before they come to
their final conclusions
thank you Miss Coley um councilor wealth
thank you I'd like to move um councilman
Stanley's proposal that we reject this
application I don't think it was
seconded thank you
second thank you I'm grateful councilor
Walsh um councilor Thomas you want to
come back in yeah I was going to Second
the uh proposal from councilman Stanley
but also I'd like to say that if SAS
windows are there and part of the
Heritage Center the whole point of the
the Heritage and the conservation being
in place is so that you can continue to
see the sash windows there is nowhere
else in that Heritage Center from my
memory where there are bifold doors
thank you thank you councilors Council a
minute
um thank you for your um for your
explanation about the um that the
windows and things
um I think I've come to my conclusion I
think that whilst um
the I I understand that the windows the
sash windows have gone the
I I do feel like and the the building is
a Heritage asset yeah the area you know
is a conservation area and without the
building being there it would look very
odd
um
having said that I think that the the
the the the the the covering of the
terrorists that how you know I don't
think it actually makes it
um doesn't make the building worse
um I think it and I could see that it
serves a purpose for the business then
that is the occupier of the building
um whoever the you know however the
building its future we don't yet know in
the next however many years but I think
that to me it's not
it's not a negative in that sense I can
understand the part of the windows I
think that things do have to evolve
slightly with time
um um I'm completely ignoring the whole
retrospective thing because it's you
know we look at the applications as they
are and and was it you know it's not we
have to look at them for for their
merits and and lack of as it were I
think that I'm on balance I'm I'm going
in favor
um I was torn just like Council Wilson
same sorts of reasons really
um and I think that really our our duty
here is to look at that to to look at
the public benefit
um and to weigh their public benefit
with with those the other parts there
are pros and cons to it and I'm going to
have to go with the public with this so
thank you very much
okay thank you councilor Menace so it's
it has been moved and seconded that we
uh Grant planning permission
um and it's also been moving seconded
that we refuse planning permission
um we will vote on granting planning
permission first because that is against
the office of recommendation so we'll go
we'll go with that vote first
and uh Miss College remind me that we
need reasons for
the grant of permission um okay Miss
Kelly is going to suggest them and I and
I assume if we were to Grant then we
would delegate authority to draft
appropriate conditions and deal with
that yeah okay
um if if members are minded to approve
the application
um I would suggest that you do so on the
basis that you do not consider that harm
arises to the to the Heritage asset as a
result uh and thus
um the uh thus it would comply with the
development plan and the advice of the
mppf I'm getting nods so no dissent from
that okay
um okay so uh councilor young we're
going to move on to the vote now and you
have spoken already so uh I don't know
if you wanted to come in but I'm not
minded to to let you so we're going to
move to the vote now to move business
along so we'll vote on
um granting uh planning permission first
so all those in favor of granting
planning permission if you could
indicate now please
okay and all those uh against granting
planning permission
okay
and uh so that motion is is not carried
so we'll vote separately now on refusing
planning permission as per officer
recommendation as well as in favor of
refusing permission if you can indicate
now please
okay and all those uh against refusing
file information okay no please
yeah okay so that uh that application uh
is refused as per officer recommendation
so upon permission is refused on that
application so thank you to all the
speakers who came to help the committee
uh with their decision
this evening
uh councilor chalkin uh is coming back
into the room now we'll move on to the
second application that we'll consider
tonight which is 209 kentmere Road in
timperley application one zero eight
four three five
um the committee members the papers
start on page one one three of the
bundle and we will start with an
introduction from Ms Milder
thank you chair
the application site is a detached
residential property on camera Road in
timperley
The Proposal is for the erection of a
single story side and rear extension in
filling the corner between the side and
I'm rear extension in addition
retrospective planning permission is
sought for two sections of fencing
one fence immediately to the front of
the property
um measuring 1.1 meters high and one
structure fencing
um to the back of payment in front of
the grass Verge measuring 0.9 meters
high and both fences have concrete posts
and Timber panels
13 objections to the fencing have been
received on the grounds of visual
amenity impact on Highway and pedestrian
safety and access
whilst officers have considered the
comments received giving considering the
sighting design and mod is height of the
fencing it is considered that they do
not cause harm to the visual or
residential amenity of the area or have
a detrimental impact on parking
provision or highway safety
the proposed extension is also of a
scale and design that is considered
appropriate in its settings and not
considered to result in harm to the
local
um Street local area or neighboring
properties in regards to amenity
therefore the application is recommended
for approval subject to the conditions
as outlined in your report
okay thank you Miss Miller is uh Mr
Chaco with us this evening
come and have a seat just opposite me uh
please Mr Taco CEO speaking against this
application
um so you'll have three minutes to speak
to us and we will start the timer once
you start speaking and ask you to
conclude your remarks if you if you run
up to the three minutes so whenever
you're ready thank you
good evening everyone thank you for
giving me an opportunity to speak today
I'm just sitting here just object the
blinding application not the whole of it
I have no objection running permission
for the rare and back extension but the
um the retrospective fences which is
erected one on the side of my driveway
between mine and my neighbors making my
driveway so narrow and it's making it so
difficult for me to get into my parking
area and I can just get in there but
it's so difficult to get out of the car
because it's always the door go and hit
on the fence uh it's not been designed
to put any fences or anything in that
open and clear area
um and as I said um we share a lot of
common area in between so I can't park
in the friend which then I'm blocking
the neighbors again so to get into my
parking lot and this fence is causing
immense problem for me and my family to
get out of the car and it's causing the
affecting my parking amenities and the
one by by the footpath which is by the
grass cage is blocking my views effect
small animal or a small child pass by
when I get out I can't see it it's
blocking my view so it's making it so
difficult for me to safely drive in and
out into the estate I think granting
permission for such fences in that open
and clear area encourage everyone else
to come up with the fences and make it
so private and making everyone's
driveway so narrow and park and if you
look at the areas there's no other
fences in the neighborhood or
um in their state and so I request you
all and you consider that and Grant
permission for the extension Mission
requested but
reject the application for their retro
respective permission for the fences
and then the reason for being my
objection in conclusion it's my
affecting my parking amenities just the
fence and it's not keeping in line with
the area and it's blocking my view
safely to drive in and out
thank you thank you Miss Jacko thank you
for your coming this evening if you just
want to return to your seats for me
please uh and then is Mr Ferguson with
us Mr Ferguson come and have a seat
you're speaking uh in favor of the
application as the applicant's sale yeah
again you'll have three minutes once you
start speaking thank you all right good
evening ladies and gentlemen with the
committee I'm addressing you this
evening because I installed a couple of
fences on my property
the boundary fronts at the front was
installed in May 2020 without any
objections to me or to the council it's
not newly a
installed as has been suggested in many
of the people have objected it was
erected simply to stop irresponsible dog
owners allowing their dogs to defecate
on my lawn which was a common problem
it's not
you can see clearly over it and if you
look at the pictures behind you you can
see that our neighbors hedge is 30 foot
high and that is what obstructs the view
when you're coming and out the drive not
my meter high fence
I've also installed a fence on the
property on the boundary to separate my
drive from my neighbor
and again this is normal a normal fence
that any householder would install to
mark their boundary this was installed
in order to protect my assets from
carelessness and clumsiness of my
neighbor and his friends and family who
access the property at 207 campmia down
that part of the drive and to stop him
continually parking on my drive which
has been an ongoing problem since he
moved in in April 2021 I came out on a
Monday morning to find the wing mirror
off my van completely hanging off and no
nobody wanted to know anything about it
nobody knew who had done it but the only
people that can access the properties on
that side is people going into my
neighbor's property later in 2021 my
neighbor started to build an extension
at the back and despite me asking him
not to he put to skip right at the end
of his drive that meant that every piece
of building material coming to the to
the extension had to come past my car
they couldn't physically get it past the
other side of the skip there wasn't room
and when that happened I was forced to
put a fence up because I've already had
one vehicle damage and I didn't want
another one damaged I didn't want to
have to have an argument about what was
going on
so During the period of the extensions
being built
my neighbor didn't do anything and then
once he had finished his extension he
set a highly aggressive solicitor onto
me who has threatened me with all sorts
and the last word in his final letters
that I received was said they were going
to take me to trial
ladies and gentlemen I ask you to Grant
permission for my fences so I can go
back to living in my home quietly
peacefully and most of all privately and
without the anxiety of another highly
aggressive solicit solicitors letter
waiting for me on my doormat when I come
home from work thank you
thank you Mr Ferguson uh looking to
members um wanted to speak on the item
now councilor Thomas
thank you Joe
um
I can say absolutely no reason
whatsoever
to refuse this application
um whether it's a neighbor dispute over
opening a car door or a wing mirror
coming off uh I do believe that
everyone's got the right to uh
reasonably and circle their land with
the fence should they want to and I can
see absolutely no reason why not and I
propose that we
accept this without delay
thank you Council Thomas councilman
Morgan I second to uh
agreed okay yeah thank you counselor Sam
sorry counselor Morgan uh thank you
chair I'm an absolute support um what um
councilor Thomas has just said I can't
say any reason for doing this um I mean
just just looking but it's number 200 I
think over the road it's got a similar
fence
um
um on it
um and actually the next door neighbor
has a a garage at the end of the drive
passed between the houses which is quite
a standard you know I'm sure other
people uh cancers around this room we've
got similar similar um it's very south
Manchester
um standard design so clearly the the
drive is expected to be able to be
utilized for for cars so I can't see any
reason at all to oppose this so um I'm
happy to support this application
thank you councilor Morgan uh councilor
minis did you want to speak on this yeah
um in in the objections of seeing that
there's I mean I don't I'm just honest
question I guess from from that
um about the um it's that then there's
not meant to be is it like a covenant
that says that you can't build you can't
build in front of a certain line you
can't put fences in between and because
it was one of the objections and I'm
just just looking at is that is that a
planning consideration
um I know that where I live uh similarly
you can't put offense between I can't
put offense between myself my neighbor I
don't I have but I haven't tried to put
offense there either but like you know
um no we're not allowed to put fences
between
um on the front drives either you could
have a hedge
um on the I have a hedge on one Edge but
not between neighbors you're not allowed
so I don't know whether that's um a
consideration here as well because it
might move all the reasons for it
um of not of not having fences in the
front
so I think it's addressed in the report
but
um the suggestion is that he's part of
the the Deeds
um so it may be a covenant against those
properties but that that's a not a
relevant planning matter because that's
a private law matter
um so I don't think that is a relevant
consideration for us but I'll just chat
with Miss Milner thank you
um councilor Hartley is correct it's uh
it's a private matter and the granting
of planning permission doesn't confer of
a consent that may be necessary so if
there is a covenant
um that would be a separate consent
regime and is separate to planning
it's also worth noting that we've not
taken their permitted development rights
away which would be a planning reason to
to look at fencing so that the site does
have plan information so just have
permitted development for certain fences
so so sorry with that with that so are
you saying that the fence is on the
permitted development would be would be
allowed the fences at the front
I'm saying as I think it's in the report
that some of the fences may be classed
as permitted development and but that's
not what this point of view what I'm
saying is whilst there may be a covenant
on the land we didn't take away their
permitted development which would have
been a planning reason to question the
fences right okay okay thank you
thank you uh any other members looking
to speak councilor bunting
very briefly I'm just going to say I'd
obviously agree with councilor Thomas
and Morgan
um the uh some uh obviously it's only
really the the uh offense aspect which
is contested anyway
and I can see it's one of those
applications where you arrived at the
site and you thought you got the wrong
place because you thought is that it
is that all I've driven over here to
look at you know I thought if I got the
wrong place are we making mountains out
of mole Hills I mean that is just I yeah
I have no idea why we're even discussing
this one this evening but we are and so
I'm simply going to a vote in the same
way as my colleagues have stated
previously I can see no earthly planning
reason why we refuse this application
thank you chairman
thank you councilor bunting any of the
members looking to speak on this item no
so it has been moved and seconded that
we uh Grant planning permission in
accordance with the officer
recommendation so we will vote on that
motion now whether to Grant permission
so Hold Us in favor of that motion if
you could indicate now please
uh and all those against
uh so that uh that motion is carried so
planning permission is is granted for
that development uh so that is the end
of the item
the third item that we'll uh consider
this evening is the land that stretford
mall
um application
107.558 starts on page one of the bundle
and we will start this item with an
introduction from uh Mr Pearson please
thank you foreign
this application relates to the northern
and Eastern sections of Stratford Mall
including King Street Kingsway the
existing multi-story car park and
landfronting Chester Road
the proposed development constitutes the
first phase of the Redevelopment of The
Wider Mills site
planning committee resolved to approve a
hybrid planning application for the wide
develop wider development of the mile
area consent for which is pending
completion of the section 106 obligation
in March this year
the key elements of the application
include the selective demolition Works
including the removal of the existing
King Street roof structure
and then on the next slides alterations
to the existing elevations of buildings
on King Street following the removal of
the roof so alterations on both sides of
King Street as you can see on the slide
there
proposals also include the introduction
of landscaping to the a56 frontage along
with more Landscaping throughout the
rest of the site
alterations to the multi-story car park
include the removal of the external ramp
and its replacement with an internal
ramp together with the creation of
retail floor space at ground floor
The Proposal is considered to be in
accordance with the development plan the
mppf and relevant local and National
planning guidance
scheme would have a major beneficial
effect on Stratford Town Center
enhancing it as a facility and
destination for residents and those
visiting the area
the submitted information demonstrates
that high quality well-designed scheme
will be delivered with appropriate
parking and access facilities for users
of the site
the developments considered to
significantly improve the appearance and
functionality of the Town Center
and this is crucial in providing a town
center which can be successfully
integrated with residential and other
uses that will come forward in later
phases Across The Wider site as well as
with existing development in the
surrounding area
officers are satisfied that the
development is acceptable in planning
terms subject to the imposition of
conditions set out in the report and
those conditions as amended in the
additional information report are such
the applications recommended for
approval
thank you Mr Pearson is rhiann Smith
with this evening
um come on have a seat opposite me Miss
Smith and uh you're speaking in favor of
the application
um and you'll have three minutes to
speak to us you just press the button on
the bottom there yeah and
um we'll start the timer whenever you
start speaking thank you okay uh good
evening members my name's Rianne Smith
from Amazon young and I'm the planning
agent for this application I would like
to thank officers for all their hard
work in producing a comprehensive report
and their and for their recommendation
for approval the Regeneration of
stretford town center is long overdue
having been identified as a key Council
objective in the adopted core strategy
and the refreshed stretford master plan
that application before you represents
the first phase of a wider Stratford
more Redevelopment which members
approved in outline earlier this year
this phase will include the removal of
the shopping center roof unlocking the
current access barriers and
reintroducing King Street as a High
Street as well as the creation of a new
covered Market Hall improvements to the
multi-story and provision of open space
and public realm improvements members
will be aware that
a very significant amount of community
and stakeholder consultation has been
undertaken during the preparation of the
application including meetings with
local residents existing businesses and
other key stakeholder groups such as
local disabled groups
feedback has been carefully considered
which has helped shape and informed
these proposals ensuring that the
development and the public realm is
accessible to all the applicants are
committed to continue to work with
stakeholders to ensure we meet the
different accessibility needs of the end
users of the development
the development fully Accords with the
development plan and will result in the
following key benefits
regeneration of sustainably located site
incorporating a mix of uses to bring
activity and Vibrance to a reimagined
town center
reinstate in Stratford High Street and
opening the site up for better
pedestrian and cycle access provision of
new areas of open space for Community
use and public realm improvements
delivering a high quality design that
reduces carbon emission through
Sustainable Building design and use of
appropriate materials increasing Town
Center employment opportunities
including spaces for smaller independent
businesses and ensuring the future
proofing of the Vitality of the Town
Center for current and future
generations to come
in summary members this application
represents the first step of a
multi-phase project in transforming the
Town Center allowing Stratford to reach
its full potential by creating a high
quality future-proofed environment which
better serves the existing community and
is where people will aspire to live work
and dwell the applicant is committed
delivering an Exemplar scheme and in
view of the full compliance with policy
and very significant benefits we would
respect for requests that you endorse
that officer's recommendation for
approval thank you
thank you Mr Smith thank you for coming
to speak to us this evening uh looking
to members now we wish to speak on this
item
councilor Proctor
thank you chair it's actually a question
I don't understand why taking the roof
off is going to make it more attractive
because people just get wet
and
can someone explain the the logic behind
that because I genuinely don't
understand thank you
well I guess it's I guess it is a
subjective uh uh Point uh I mean in our
opinion that the male obviously been
there since I think the early 70s and uh
it effectively closes in the evening you
can't really access most of the Town
Center
and
you know I've been struggling as well
that the male had the town center and we
think these proposals will it will
introduce a traditional streets and and
yes you're right when it's raining you
will get wet if you walk down there
um but only if it's raining
um but but it will allow people greater
access through through the site and I
think you know from our perspective on
the applicant's perspective and I think
a lot of the response that we've had for
members of the public has been extremely
positive
um and um yeah we just think it will be
a good thing it will it will make the
site more more lively
um people will be able to to visit shops
shops will be able to set their own
opening times closing times within
reason
um so we just think it will have a
positive beneficial effect on the on the
town center
thank you um councilor win Stanley thank
you next
uh thank you chair and just a thank you
to Mr Pearson for explaining the
principle of getting wet when it rains
I'm
obliged to you
thank you it's always good to have a
professional in the room
brilliant
um joking aside I have no um no
hesitation and absolutely proposing we
accept this plan as it as it currently
stands it will restore I think uh
Stratford to some of its former glories
and to restore the original Street plan
um and uh everything that goes with that
to give Stratford his Town Center back I
think so yeah I'd probably accept the
this in lab loss recommendation thank
you
thank you councilman Stanley uh
councilor Thomas
thank you chair also you get well when
it snows but I'd like to uh second The
Proposal from councilman Stanley
thank you uh councilor Thomas um
councilor Freeman
thank you chair
um
I think it's a really really
comprehensive report and I'm grateful to
officers for presenting it the way they
have
um a welcome I think it's an exciting
application it marks a key moment in our
plans to regenerate Stratford now and
let's not forget who bought Stratford
mail
um it's a this is a start on the coming
well the commencement of many years of
hard work and consultation uh that have
gone into making this application a
reality uh and I've also in that I'd
like to pay a tribute to the current
leader of the council in driving this
forward as well
um and so I look forward to seeing
construction start on the site and
people start to get a Stratford Town
Center that they can be proud of and
that they deserve thank you foreign
very much welcome this proposal I had to
walk down to Stratford Mall today in it
and and it's clear to everybody who
visits and it does need uh renovation
does need improvements and that that's
exactly what this this work is going to
do I I would just I would have thought
that that street scene with without the
roof now on King Street it'll make it
more alive we make make it a more more
exciting venue in the evening that's the
issue and councilor Mr Pearson said
um it does close down in the evening and
we want that evening economy you know
people want to go out to restaurants and
uh quite reasonable and why can't we do
it in Stratford and hopefully they'll do
that so very much welcome this this
application chair thank you thank you
councilwash uh councilor Hassan
thank you chair
I've been the part of this consultation
for many years and
it is around a matter of day or months
it has been consulted for many years
and Stratford Mall was to be considered
as a ghost town and people used to
travel all the way to Amsterdam or
towards to Town Center for shopping
seven years ago there was only I mean
there were about 300 people gathered in
the Town Center to consult what is the
solution of this Stratford Mall and we
are really lucky enough
uh it is going to be regenerated and and
and particularly for the small and
medium Enterprise businessman those been
barely suffered uh unemployment and it's
had affected families
and and I think it is it will be
a very beautiful addition and it would
be called a Stratford Town Center
and and I fully support uh office's
recommendation thank you
thank you Council son
um just oh councilor wealth I'll come to
you first and then I was going to speak
myself thank you uh thank you Echo what
other members say I will um draw
attention to former Council
accordingly's um uh response where he I
mean he did he was talking about the the
look of one particular side of the the
development and I think he's got you
know a fair point then but it's
certainly not not nothing you know that
the vast majority of the scheme is
absolutely fantastic and I'm
particularly looking you know looking
forward to you know when we have nice
things that happen in Autry and people
won't be able to moan anymore that
everything nice happens in Ultra which
is going to be absolutely fantastic as a
local War councilor so very much looking
forward to uh um them getting cracking
with the work thank you
thank you councilor Welton I'll speak
brief on this just to say you know I
agree with the other speakers I'm really
excited about the application
um we've been talking about the
Regeneration of Stratford for many many
years and um I know we've improved the
previous application but this is the
first part that we're granting for
planning permission for so I think it's
uh it's a real Landmark the the I think
the full advantages of the Regeneration
won't all become apparent just with this
first phase so in particular you know
Kingsway and adjusting that will all
have to come later but but I think this
is really exciting I think opening up
the street is great uh I think I think
the landscaping that's proposed is
really good particularly along Chester
Road
um and the the carbon uh the reduction
in carbon emissions is really good to
see they're really significant
um and I think it will it will just make
Stratford feel like a tone again with
active frontages
um you know traditional streets
um and the market as well underneath the
car park so I think this is is a really
good application I'm really excited
about it and I'll also be voting in
favor
um any other members looking to speak I
will move to the vote councilor Proctor
thank you I actually remember when King
Street was King Street
um downtown Center was the the standout
Center built in the UK
um in the very early 1970s and for quite
some time afterwards King Street existed
as its own Street and where woolies used
to be
wasn't part of the Arndale Center so
apart from getting wet
it looks prettier than the Arndale
Center certainly is so anything that
improves the environment there
has got to be a good thing
thank you Council Proctor I think
straightforlando was opened by Muhammad
Ali and Diana doors wasn't it as a
different different era I'm not sure I'm
not sure we'll get celebrities of that
stature to uh to who knows who knows
um
probably wasn't born at that time but
I've seen the photos
um will vote it's been moving seconded
that we that we grant funding permission
uh for this so we'll move to the vote on
that all those in favor of granting and
filing permission
thank you and all those against
that issue unanimous thank you very much
members
um so that is the uh
end of that item so the next item we'll
move on to is
um application 107 854 which is the sale
West estate uh starts on page 41 of the
bundle uh for members and we'll start
this item with our introduction from
Miss Coley thank you thank you thank you
chair
the application sizes referred to
collectively as for sale West estate
and is located at the Western extremity
of the residential area of sale
this application relates to the approval
of Reserve matters with regards to
appearance Landscaping layout and scale
pursuant to outline planning application
103697 this was a hybrid application
which included full approval for 79
dwellings in Phase One and outline
approval for the erection of up to 184
dwellings in later phases with all
matters reserved with the exception of
access to the site phase one works I.E
those that relates to full approval have
already commenced and are well Advanced
on site
this Reserve batter's application
relates to 18 dwellings in total along
with wider estate Landscaping works and
play areas and works to park in courts
and footpaths and is referred to as
phase two of the development
all 18 dwellings will be provided as
affordable housing in the form of social
rented properties
the proposed residential units can price
14 one-bedroom apartments two
two-bedroom apartments and two
two-bedroom dwelling houses and all
properties are two-story at the
one-bedroom apartments being one at
ground floor one at first floor
um the principal of the residential
development has been
um accepted through the grant of the
hybrid application
but now all detail matters have been
assessed including the main areas of
consideration of appearance Landscaping
layout and scale the proposal has been
found to be acceptable with where
appropriate specific litigation secure
by planning condition and The Proposal
complies with the development plan and
the policy in the mppf officers
therefore recommend that the application
is approved thank you
thank you Miss curly uh councilor Duncan
um you're speaking against this
application I think so we'll hear from
you first thank you for your patience in
waiting for this item uh if you want to
sorry yeah come to the chair opposite me
and uh
just make sure the microphone is on
um there's a ward counselor you'll have
five minutes to speak to us and we'll
start a timer once you start speaking so
whenever you're ready thank you lovely
okay right thank you very much chairman
and thank you very much members for
allowing me the time to speak
um I have been asked to speak on behalf
of a number of residents no clearly it's
not against the whole bill don't get me
wrong
um
these these residents have just asked me
to highlight tonight of a block of four
Apartments
um on the existing well-used car park
located on Hurst Avenue
now this car park is opposite Saint
Margaret's school only
okay which I believe it to be Zone D and
just to reiterate chairman and members
um at no other part of the application
is in question
so with regards to the car park on Zone
D
um on paper it just clearly looked
fantastic okay and of course we all need
new housing stock to meet demand
of course affordable hoses too now I
know erwell Valley I've been working
hard given this Redevelopment
however
with regards to the potential build on
Zone D Hurst Avenue car park
we do have a community
that is very very concerned about what
would happen should this car park
be taken away from them
okay now local residents have assured me
that they've managed to get a petition
of just under 300 people that have
objected
and the local head teacher at St
Margaret's has a voice his worries
regarding the lack of parking for
drop-offs and pick up
okay so a few concerns that the
residents have asked me to speak on
their behalf about and they include
reduced parking for the score runs
resulting in congestion
reduced parking for existing residents
who in some cases have two cars
further reduction of an already limited
Green Space
now if the apartments are built it will
most definitely cause an over spill onto
a very busy Cherry Lane
so by building these extra Apartments
this will only add to the extra traffic
and more problems with parking on an
already congested area
now residents have thanked Earl Valley
for the thought process of the extra
planting of trees and shrubs Etc
and residents are asking for their car
park not to be built on
an alternative location found if
possible and I've been told and I
understand and a location has been put
forward
um for those block of apartments in
between Apartments 139 and 140.
if this is not an option the residents
have asked mitsu simply put forward
come the car park stay as it is
and this part of the application if it
is refused the view said could we please
uh sorry could you please take that into
consideration thank you very much indeed
chairman and members
okay thank you thank you councilor
Duncan um
I think yeah so we've got another
speaker but I think if I turn to miss
cohenow just for some advice on the
um
okay now let's uh it is
um is Heather Lynley clap with us
if you have um have a seat just opposite
me and just make sure the microphone is
is on it should have a red light on the
end
um and uh you'll have um three minutes
to speak to us in in favor of the
application and um ask you to just wrap
up your remarks if you run up to the
three minutes okay so whenever you're
ready thank you
thank you chair for allowing me to
address the committee this evening my
name is Heather Lindley Clapp director
of Nexus planning and I'm speaking on
behalf of my client uh World Valley
homes in respect to the proposal before
you we welcome your officer's
recommendation to approve the planning
application confirming that the scheme
is policy compliant and represents a
sustainable development on a key
Brownfield site working extensively
alongside the community and traffic
Council uh well Valley homes is
committed to delivering their
multi-million pound regeneration program
at sail west which is included in the
Trafford local plan as a priority
regeneration area
this will improve existing homes and
develop new homes to meet the housing
needs of the borough and deliver Place
making initiatives through community-led
collaboration
the First new build phase which is
nearly now complete includes the
provision of 79 new affordable homes
The Proposal in front of you this
evening represents the second phase of
the project bringing forward an
additional 18 affordable dwellings that
will be delivered as low carbon homes
future phases within what within the
wider estate are currently being
explored with the potential to deliver
an additional 162 new affordable homes
as part of the overall master plan
continuing to work with the community
and stakeholders the separate elements
of the development before you have been
designed to ensure that the proposed
dwellings are sympathetic to their
surroundings whilst creating a high
quality scheme which significantly
improves the Aesthetics of the eight
individual Parcels within the
application site the just under half of
the new homes in this application will
be designed to be adaptable ready
this means that the dwellings will
include wider corridors and doorways
wheelchair turning circles where
possible level access and full wet rooms
these units will provide much needed
adaptable accommodation for people with
disabilities and we anticipate that they
will be very much in demand
the development will include Place
making improvements to public areas of
open space including an encrypt play
area along with improvements to public
footpaths and existing Park courts
additional Landscaping is also proposed
within the estate to enhance the built
environment of the new dwellings and
wider area
we have worked proactively with your
officers to ensure that the application
was supported by robust technical
evidence to demonstrate that the
development would not harm the adjacent
neighbors enjoyment of their properties
we have also ensured that the proposal
is supported by detailed technical
highways evidence which has been
accepted by the council's highways
officer which demonstrates that there
are no adverse impacts associated with
traffic generation and that appropriate
parking and wider access can be provided
including the provision of accessible
spaces and wider footpaths where
possible
this scheme has benefited from the
support of homes England with Grant
secured through the affordable homes
program plus the greater Manchester
combined Authority with a contribution
of 550 000 Brownfield land funding to
enable the scheme to be delivered
thank you for your time today and we
hope you will support this much needed
Redevelopment which will contribute
positively to meeting the council
shortfall and housing and bringing much
needed affordable properties to this
part of Trafford
thank you thank you uh thank you for
coming and speaking to us
um so I'll turn to miss Carly now just
to give us some advice about the the
parking concerns in zone D which uh
councilor Duncan referenced
thank you chair
um just just to say
um the planning service did not receive
a petition or anything from the head
teacher of the school
um I'm not doubting what council Duncan
said but we haven't been able to take
those into account because we haven't
seen them
um
so in in terms of uh Zone D
um that's an area which does have
um a fair amount of parking in and
around it on on Hurst Avenue and Castle
is quite correct that it is opposite the
the primary school there however
um the proposals
um when they are laid out only
um lead to a net reduction of one car
parking space overall and uh within that
two specifically accessible car parking
spaces will be formed
um there is
um
again I mean this committee deals with
issues of traffic around schools all the
time
um and yes undoubtedly it will be busy
at school time but there's lots and lots
of other parking in around the estate
the estate has consent for 184
additional dwellings of which
um 17 oh sorry
184 on top of the 79 that that were full
so we've already gone to permission for
four this is another 18. so we're only
22 in so two now start
um rejecting Reserve multiple you can't
reject a reserve but on parking grounds
because if you were going to do that
um that needed to be done at the outline
stage if there was concerns about
overspill parking
um in any event
um officers viewers this more than looks
after itself in terms of parking needs
and and we don't believe that the
adverse impacts that the residents
identify would actually take place in
practice given the ability to rearrange
the parking and and the
um negligible net loss that that we see
thank you
thank you Miss Kelly it's very useful
um any members looking to speak
counselor bunting
nothing cancel both was before me
apologize I didn't see you in a cane
that's very gracious of you um
thank you
thank you no I said yeah thank you um
obviously this is my ward I know this
area well I I know the car part we're
referring to and I I accept that some
residents will have concerns
um regarding the development there are
problems with the way over Valley is
going about developing redeveloping but
that's not to do with this application
and therefore I'm going to uh leave my
concerns about the general Redevelopment
to one side into as Mrs Kobe has already
pointed out the parking loss in terms of
this is Tiny its name is one they say
one that one that net loss I don't think
it will have a significant impact yes
there are going to be problems around
around that school and yes that will
give me problems with with parking with
people dropping off and all the rest of
it but then again there are every other
school that you ever did see
um overall I think the the the the
development as a whole and this
application in particular is is a
positive uh Improvement on the area
there are many other positive
improvements that need to be uh pushed
forward uh and and there were many
positive improvements that have already
occurred in the past so I think the area
generally is much improved than it was
when we uh when I first saw started in
with this all those years ago so I don't
whilst I accept that the residents have
their concerns and I I I I I don't think
it's going to cause problems that
they're envisaging and uh but then again
often is not the the fear of what's
about to happen is far worse than what
actually does and so I I'm happy to
propose that we accept the officer
recommendation to Grant thank you
chairman thank you Council bunting
councilman
okay thanks chair um
I have to say I struggled a bit with
this application and I'll um let me try
and explain myself
I'm presuming that the the sites for
these
um eight Parcels of land were were
identified in the outline application
and um I did struggle marrying the
drawings with the particular locations
so
this this so there's eight different
parcels and uh there's 18 sites all to
18 properties
um and some house types fit into more
than one's own
and uh
I've looked at it over the weekend and
certainly the locations were fine but I
do I really did struggle with the
drawings and um
it struck me that
um eight individual Parcels
um
warranted more more pages written about
them uh
the feeling on this application is we've
had the the the broad outline previously
and and we're so desperately need houses
um
as councilor Duncan has said
um and we all know that but I do think
that's done at the expense of going into
detail about individual sites in this
application and I'd be interesting what
other members think about identifying
house types against particular zones
um
but that aside as far as I did get I do
have concerns about the balconies that
are on two or three different types of
houses
um I didn't see the ones that I looked
at I didn't see balconies similar to
that in the area
and it felt to me as though we were
installing something that wasn't in
keeping
um with the surrounding houses
um
so I do have a difficulty with that and
not all the prop the new properties have
bulk is but the ones that do I feel
do not compliment uh what's there
previously so
um
I'm interested in what other members
think but at the moment uh chair I'm
looking to not not support the
application for the reason that I do
feel it it deserves more detail I think
our our enthusiasm to to to build to
provide new housing that we desperately
need I think is made as has had this uh
rapport
report being been written in Broad terms
and I think you deserved more detail and
I mean arguably you know eight Parcels
of land eight diff eight different
um items and certainly I feel it
delivered more attention but I'm
interested in what other members think
thank you very much Jay
thank you Council Walsh uh any other
members looking to speak on this item
councilor shocking
uh thank you I actually agree with
councilor Walsh there
um in the sense that when I was reading
I I was confused at the beginning it was
really hard to get my head around the
the um plans just 230 odd documents on
online it's a lot to go through
um it probably did warrant more time
um it just felt it feels to me as though
they've started Works they've found
these sites and decided just to go and
build what they can on on pieces of land
that they can find and
I actually didn't pick up on the balcony
but I actually thought the design at the
exterior design was actually quite in
keeping but that's probably personal
um Choice what I did pick up on was the
size of the space inside particularly
for the accessible apartments and this
is where I think more did more time
spent on the details necessary because
it just felt like they're far too small
they were in the parameters but for
wheelchair users or
um for what we what we what the lower
value are trying to do
I just didn't think it was suitable so I
do actually agree with you
um on that probably more time was is
deserved on it
um but with respect to the application
of runs first I don't know
um
I'd be willing to learn
um here where you could where we can
turn around and say actually no we need
to maybe
postpone this or look at it again or
um so a welcome thoughts on that
[Music]
um
yeah I think I think it was difficult to
follow
um I guess that in part is the nature of
the development which is sort of in
filling small Parcels of land so
um
yeah it's difficult to sort of treat it
in an easy way as one site so yeah I
think I think that was uh difficult I'll
uh maybe ask Miss College to do some
advice on
how those passes of land were identified
because my recollection as it was set
out in the outline application so not
not the
specific housing types but but they you
know the parcels of land that will be
used for the development
yes the
although
um and I would need to check this
exactly may not have actually pointed to
um each of the sites and said this is
what will be on these it did identify
the the there were a number of
opportunities for the development of
infill sites and sites where there had
been previously been demolitioned in
across a number of phases
um and uh it was demonstrated adequately
that 184 units could be fitted on that
land that was was identified
we can't roll back from that
um
I I do understand why members
might have
um find found it initially difficult to
follow because I agree there are lots
and lots of plans
um I'm not sure you'd have preferred
eight individual applications to
determine this evening
um I certainly wouldn't have done
um and I I I have to say I I don't agree
with the criticism of the detail in the
reports I do think it could actually
have been written more concisely had the
officer chosen to allow a different case
officer may have written it more
concisely because that is there that's
their style I think it goes into all the
detail it needs to and assesses every
single one of the plots you know for all
the relevant
um means and yes there's a lot of
information but all that info all the
information members need to make a
decision tonight I believe is in in that
application and I don't think
um we can we can't
we can't defer the application on a lack
of information because I'm not sure what
else earlwell Valley or the planning
service could do to give you more
information rather other than take you
through it step by step
thank you uh thank you Miss College I
mean it might it might just be a
question of
um working on the planning portal and
there's a list of 230 documents I think
it's against the chalking said and
um I just thought if if there could be
split into folders see you had Zone a
Zone B all the general stuff but just
just to make it easy to navigate for
members of the committee are members of
the public might be something to bear in
mind for future applications like this
but I don't know if that's possible that
would be absolutely wonderful if the
software allowed us to do that yeah I
thought that might be the case worth
asking worth asking
um
um okay sorry cancel I went down there
you wanted to speak on this yeah uh
thank you I was going to say the same
thing about folders actually the first
thing I was going to say would make it
easier because it's a it's a balancing
act isn't it for the officers to provide
all the necessary information I'm not
overwhelming us and I suspect the
instinct is to provide more rather than
less if it was organized better if your
software would allow it to be organized
better that would that would help no end
I wanted to return to the the issue of
the
um the accessible apartments
um because it's been still together much
debate prior to
this meeting
um
and I think it revolves around it's
first of all is the timing of the
request made to wearable Valley and I
think they've come back on a fairly late
stage with some with some changes to
planned which already existed
and they've come back with some changes
they'll have some wet rooms and to allow
hat Flats which on the ground floor
which are adaptable as opposed to being
already adapted but as the same means
they've got wider doorways and
um level access we also asked some
questions about the possibility upon
lifts into these things
um
the again it's a bit later in the design
to make the request I think is why the
lifts could not be put in there was
there was another point which was the
the cost of the maintenance of the lift
has to be added on to the social rent in
the in the apartments
I don't know how it works in terms of
adding on the cost of lifts across the
specific apartments or across the whole
scheme but I lived in a Housing
Association property about 10 years ago
which had an inbuilt lift and we paid
the maintenance costs as part of that
rent it was a 10 or a month there's no
way a 10 or a month was going to cover
the maintenance cost that left so I
suspect there's a way of amortizing
across the whole development as opposed
to just the individual places which have
left
having said all that overall I think
I'll be voting in favor of this
development just a way to stand at the
moment and with the last minute changes
in terms of accessibility
um I think we're too far down the road
with these Parcels of land now to change
some substantially from what we've
already done in the last week or so so
I'll be boating in favor of the
proposals as it stands including the
items laid out in the additional
information report thank you chair thank
you again for Mr councilor Freeman
thank you chair I'm glad for Miss Cole's
Clarity on on on on the application and
where we're up to with it it's 18
dwellings for social rent what does this
Borough need it needs this sort of
housing I welcome the the changes that
erwa Valley have brought through in
terms of the uh disability access it's
not perfect we could say that but look
we need housing and these are Brownfield
sites and and and there's such a lot of
work gone into this and it is a detailed
report it probably is as much courses
over detail it's probably that's what's
probably made it more confusing really
but an outline plan permission was given
we're down the road with this we needed
them to get on with it we need to build
housing in this area which is very very
much in demand and this meets that
criteria and so I will second The
Proposal that that councilwin Stanley
has made that we approve uh this
planning application tonight
digital proposal well I'll propose that
I'll propose our second I'll second then
thank you
thank you cancer Freeman any other
members I can speak councilor Proctor
thank you chair I'm actually quite
relieved that the former chair of
planning with many more years experience
than me planning found this difficult to
understand because
it took ages looking at which houses
which Flats go into it which bit and if
your software can't do it your software
can't do it
I'd like to
um
say how glad I am to see
some lifetime homes being built in
Trafford
all homes should be lifetime homes and I
will keep on saying this and saying this
and saying this until I'm probably dead
and buried
um so I'm I welcome some finally some
lifetime homes thank you
thank you Council Potter Council bunting
did you want to come back thank you
chairman it's been very much in the
evening of Firsts even after all these
years on planning committee first of all
councilor Freeman agreed with me and
then and then we've heard uh that we
can't have this application there aren't
enough pages to read I mean he Gods who
who would who were the thought coming
into this into this meeting this evening
that that will be the case but no being
serious from a moment I I very much
sympathize with members on this
committee um I'm a ward member for this
for this area and I I it is an absolute
Patchwork quilt of separate little plots
and the uh Redevelopment of this of this
estate is not like a usual Redevelopment
where it's a broad sweeping areas it's
lots of bits of infill bits that were
not built on for whatever reason in the
past bits where the where previous
developments were taken down but it's
originally meant to be a later phase
that never happened the idea that people
are confused about this I'm confused
about this and I live live only a short
distance away and represent the area
half the time you should try leafleting
it it's an absolute it's an absolute
nightmare to find your way around
finding Hurst is easy finding number 32
takes you another 20 minutes after that
it's it's it is a difficult area it
doesn't surprise me but I do think this
development is a positive contribution
to it there'll be many more bits of it
so if you've enjoyed this bit this
evening just hang around I'll be the
next no longer in a short while
yeah is it is it the radburn system
which seems to mean you never know where
you're at the front or the back of the
houses that's what I've always found on
honestly
[Music]
um I'll just I'll just say I'm I'm
really uh you know strongly supportive
of the application it's a key part of
the core strategy that this West estate
is regenerated and the extra housing is
provided on that estate and this is
obviously a small part of that but it
will come forward in these phases I'm
sure and the housing mix meets the needs
of of the sale area which is important
and as councilor Freeman's mentioned
it's 100 socially rented housing which
is again is a key priority for the area
so all of those things I think is the
report says I would give significant
weight to and
um I'm struggling to see much in the way
of of any sort of adverse aspects of
this I think the levels of accessibility
are really good to be honest to to have
them uh or most of them to be adaptable
and accessible
um and then the latest information with
with the wet rooms being being fully
accessible to m43 standards so I think
in terms of accessibility this is really
good and I think the uh you know the
developer has gone you know a long way
to find a scheme that you know fits
housing into these Parcels uh and at the
same time improves the area it improves
the Landscaping it improves the parking
areas uh it widens the footways so you
know all of that is is great in terms of
access I think so I'm happy to support
the application
so any of the members looking to speak
on this item
uh so it has been moved and seconded
that we
um Grant planning permission as per the
officer recommendation
um so we're both in that motion now so
all those in favor of Grants uh please
[Music]
and all those against please
yeah so that application uh is carried
the motion is carried and the planning
permission is granted for the
application so thank you for all the
contributions on on that item uh we'll
move on uh now to
templemore Infant School
um which is application 108 516
this starts on page one two one of the
bundle and we'll start with an
introduction from Ms Milner thank you
thank you chair
the application site is Temple more
Infant School which includes on-site
school nursery provision
the application is for extensions and
alterations to help facilitate the
increase from a two-form entry to a
three-form Entry School that's 90
additional pupils
there are relatively minor alterations
to the main School building including
extensions of the hall into a storage
area over internal rearrangements
replacement entrance doors and the
canopy and cutting to the front entrance
a more significant extension is proposed
to the nursery building which would
provide two new classrooms and
Associated facilities along with
reconfiguration of the nursery
playground
vision of external plant a covered
storage and play area there's also
changes to the car parking to increase
the number of Spaces by full
and through the applications Amendments
have been sought to address highway
safety concerns and following the
original submission of um which included
a new access from James Street
which has now been removed from the
scheme 13 objections were received on
this application 12 of which did relate
to the access which is now being removed
from James Street and that followed
discussions with ourselves and the
um local highways Authority
um
the other objection focused on the
impact in regards to residential amenity
and that was from a resident on Woodall
close
um and they were particularly concerned
about the screening along the School
boundary adjacent to their property
officers have reviewed the plan and
consider that whilst the comments are
valid and the extensions and alterations
are of appropriate design and scale and
consider given the constraints of the
site
we do acknowledge there is limited
parking but considering given the site
in the context they would um on balance
be acceptable I would draw members
attention to the fact that we have
um sought to attach a condition
regarding a cycle parking strategy the
current cycle parking proposed
um is significantly below sbd3 guidance
and in regards to encouraging people and
staff and students to cycle or scoot to
their site we do feel there are many
opportunities on the site to increase
that provision so rather than hold up
the application we feel we can discuss
that through the discharge of condition
and process
um so subject to the conditions outline
in your report and we are recommending
approval thank you chair
thank you Miss Milner um there are no
speakers on this item so I'd look to
members of the committee concert Thomas
thank you chair um I was going to bring
up uh
sorry recommendation 13. the word house
I do apologize uh can we can we answer
the words that we should get that up to
meet the requirements of sdb spd3 uh in
terms of cycling provision or bar
recycling parking provision I think that
would be wise also would all close I'm
I'm concerned as some of the uh
oh entries in the applications as to how
that is going to be affected by the uh
walkway between the end of world or
close and the nursery people will
invariably aim to park on wood or close
now
that doesn't turn me against this but
it's a wider thing uh and I think that
perhaps it's more of a council thing
where we need to have safer streets
around schools and we we should be
perhaps as a council looking to extend
to very successful ones we have in m41
but I in generally am impressed by this
and I'm quite happy to propose although
uh like I said I'd like
the cycle parking strategy to include
meeting spd3 thank you
[Music]
um Miss Miller did you want to just
advise on those two points if you could
please thank you
um in regards to spd3 I think it would
be in excess of 100 Cycle parking spaces
um
I would advise that if we we are to
expand the condition it could be to seek
to achieve and so that the design is is
kind of and the need is looked up
properly rather than just going for a
number we look what's best for the site
and what's best for the needs of the
um the school so we can certainly seek
to maximize the cycle parking but I
would be hesitant to stipulate an exact
figure at this stage absolutely agree
with that that's fine yeah
[Music]
um thank you sorry the other point
councilor Thomas mentioned was um wood
old close and I don't I don't think
there's any access from wall or close
into the school is that right yeah no
there isn't
do you know mention pedestrians
this is what we're internally that would
go past the the side of wood or close
but the access is from Nursery close
sorry Myra I'll show up
thank you Miss Miller uh councilor Welsh
thanks yeah I hope I'm not going to be
putting the spanner in the works um I
was surprised chair that we didn't have
any comments from Nursery close or
Temple Road and I just wanted to make
sure that we'd actually written to them
um this uh with a new class opening and
uh within three years we'll have 90 new
pupils at school and it did surprise me
now she closely I looked today but I
couldn't see the list of um
consultation in regarding the residents
um
as far as I'm aware we consulted in a
quart of rsci which would include
include all
um adjacent neighbors and the fact that
we received such a high level of
response from James Street and from um
the comment from model Street gives me
confidence that we certainly consulted
in accordance with rsci
um
I do know your point though
um but I think the the main concern was
the new access
um just just to continue with that um
I'm aware we've we've asked for a travel
plan to from school within three months
I think it said
um
we all know you know parents do drive to
school and and and and use the cow prep
we encourage people not to do so
but I I can see an issue arising here
when so many uh
new children with the new classroom
starting and I just wondered
around the travel plan if there are
issues for example on Nursery Avenue and
Temple Road
presumably those parents would approach
school with the concerns and that would
be dealt with I just wonder does the
travel travel plan formalize that so
presumably the head teacher would be
um the transport
there's a title they've got to have them
there
TP something
yeah so present with the tattoo she
would I mean it'd be interested in what
our traffic officer said but I can just
for sale I'm absolutely in favor of the
application the design is fine it's much
needed but just around the residence
surprised it and they didn't get in
touch but being kind of uh
I was looking on the bad side if you
like three you know a few months down
the line any issues that crop up they'll
be able to be dealt with within the
travel plan
thanks chair
thank you councilor Walsh uh I might ask
Miss Miller if she's got any advice to
give on that and then miss hendren as
well just around the the travel planning
I know this is a common issue we have um
around around schools you know parking
is always always a concern thank you
just to confirm we did consult Nursery
close residents And in regards to
highways and travel plan I would
um defer to the lha
thank you Miss hendren that's useful um
councilor understand that you wanted to
speak
no I've got a good Barry first and then
you okay thank you chair uh overall in
favor of this
um when I did the side visit I was lucky
enough to be shown around by the
business manager of this of the school
I'm very open and honest in the way
um answered my questions
I also asked her the same question that
councilor Walsh asked about the fact
that there were certain streets on there
didn't they didn't hadn't responded to
the
um hadn't responded to the uh
consultation and her answer was they
don't normally get complaints from those
streets the complaints they've only ever
really had is the street in front of the
school which I think is a comment around
the streets and the um and the street
where they were going to put the new
entrance in which is James Street I
think from from memory and they had
changed the plans in line with the the
objections raised by by those residents
I was reassured by the fact that the uh
there's a travel plan is going to be
required as part of the the approval
process one thing I would like to
request and I think is something we can
put into the
um
into the the planning uh permission
is that there is some plan around
increasing the number of accessible
parking spaces
um the car parking space on there is
extremely small the cars are crammed in
now as it stands so I'm not sure what
that would look like in terms of a
planning recommendation or a condition
on the
uh on there on the record on the record
one on the permission but I'm happy to
give that to officers to come up with
the appropriate wording if that's
acceptable yeah
to improve the number of to increase the
number of accessible parking spaces
uh so it's well to that proposal from
councilwin Stanley don't we that we try
and craft a condition to increase the uh
the number of accessible parking spaces
I um I mean it is tight I guess I guess
logic dictates that more accessible
spaces probably means less parking
overall so that's probably the the
balance there
um
so that came to the Freeman if I come to
you because I know you've been itching
to get in and then we'll maybe return to
that
I'll come to the car park in the amount
in a minute there's been a huge amount
of consultation on this application
before it even got to planning the
schools unit did a huge amount of
consultation with residents on Alice
street Nursery close James Street Temple
Road there were two consultation events
which residents were invited to I know
my colleague councilor Patel attended
those and and there were residents
present as a result of that consultation
that's where the proposal has come to to
close the the entry that was proposed
for for James Street uh that's that's
because there has been resident
consultation right the way through
this is a school this is a pro an infant
school this is a school from nursery and
then from reception to seven years of
age because after that the ship out down
the road to Temple Mall which is another
school which you're expanding
um and so we need the schools we need
the school places so don't be under any
doubt about the amount of consultation
that's gone on
if you read through the report there was
a huge amount of concern about access to
the site for the construction through
James Street that is being taken care of
by a very very well-worded management
plan for the construction site so that's
the sort of consultation that has gone
on
um and uh and so I I think I I really do
well welcome the report now as for car
parking every school has a problem with
it Barry every single school I'm chair
of guns at Springfield we've got a car
park that isn't big enough but we manage
and it's incumbent on that head and and
the management of the school to manage
with what they are given
as for active travel we've got to
promote active trouble of pupils to
school this idea that parents have got
to take kids to school and we sit and
worry about it as a committee while they
drop off the school and
us as counselors have got a role to play
here in getting kids walking to school
and scooting to school and and getting
fresh air on the way to school if it can
be achieved where I'm terrible there's
96 of our children actually don't come
to school buy a car other schools can do
the same that's that's but that's for
them it's not for me a planning
consideration
we need school places we need this
expansion and I'm going to vote in favor
of the of the application
thank you thank you Council Freeman uh
any other members looking to speak
either on the application or on on
councilwin Stanley's proposal are
unaccessible parking so councilor Thomas
I'll come to you first
thank you yeah I completely agree yeah
whilst the parking is tight
there is a definitive need for
accessible parking
um we can't shy away from this going
forward and
okay maybe on the up to the head to
ensure that people travel to school in
the most appropriate way
uh it's people that require accessible
parking that have the greatest
difficulty in getting to and from places
so I think the condition to increase
as debated perhaps but to increase
accessible parking is crucial
thank you Council Thomas councilmanis
um
um I just want to say very well Santa
comes with him yes
insightful Etc and I think that you know
it's important for us actually when what
those of us with young children to
actually try and promote that for other
parents and you know make them think
about I did it today I said say to
somebody who I could just walk
um and then she said well she said well
you know you live that it's the same
distance as I do from school so um you
know it's that sort of thing I think
that um the accessible parking you do
need because there are people who aren't
going to be able to do that
um so I think that's necessary I think
the I'm kind of like a I'm not a fan of
the general parking thing because it
just encourages the wrong behavior
um so the accessible barking yes the
let's let's encourage people to drive
their kids to school no
um thank you well otherwise I'm a favor
thank you Council Minister Welton
uh yes uh just uh three points I think
if there's a net gain of four
um four parking places I think certainly
we can afford that to be a net gain of
three parking spaces and a an increasing
accessibility so I'd definitely back
um that proposition I think it's quite
it's quite quite a shame that the
proposal for James Street was
um which I can understand why that was
that was objected to by the residents
I'm it's a sad that you can't have a
bolt-on School Street to go with
something like that because you know if
you've got to create more you know
schools are on a bigger state if you
create multiple access points then more
people are like more likely to walk so
it's actually you know really
self-defeating for the whole for the
area as a whole not to create more
access points like that and you know
that's something for the council to to
address and and unfortunately the school
streets scheme is failing at the moment
because of a lack of capacity but that's
not an issue for this
um committee I want to say thank uh
thank the designers of this development
for the solar array of course the
schools are having all sorts of problems
financially at the moment in terms of
energy
um you know and this is one way that
they can contribute both to The Wider
fight against the climate emergency but
also to their own financial situation by
having those panels so fantastic and we
look forward to seeing more schools
doing the same around the borough
thank you Council Wilson councilor
bunting I was just going to say well in
one point I would agree with Council
Wilson on is that yes more more access
points would reduce the issues
surrounding parking obviously you're not
going to walk to school if you've got to
walk all the way around to get to one
main one main entrance point in terms of
the accessibility parking and the
increasing numbers yes that will
decrease the number of overall parking
spaces now obviously we need to make
sure we've got sufficient but we don't
want to reduce that too much the idea
that if you don't provide
parking spaces parents won't drive their
children to school that's for the birds
you might as well wish every child in
school to have a pet unicorn is it
that's a nonsense if you don't provide
parking spaces all happen as a parent or
part wherever they wherever they can fit
their car I've been with schools in
my wood where the horrendous problems
with parking we've had to get extra WL
lines put in on the corner of Junctions
and all the rest of it to stop people
just parking wherever they could because
there wasn't enough parking simply
restricting parking thing or if we do
that parents or walk
isn't going to happen it's just that
they will just find somewhere to dump
their car while they drop little Jimmy
at the school thank you chairman thank
you cancer bunting um
so that a number of members have spoken
in favor of uh the conditions requiring
a greater level of accessible parking
gonna just looking to miss Mill knows to
whether we can do that and how we might
do it thank you so we can definitely add
a condition on um I think we could
probably look at the car parking
management strategy so we can review
with the school to look at demand and
look how they would reconfigure their
car park and but as the reason you know
X to improve accessibility so again
rather than stipulate numbers but
understand the reason behind it to seek
to maximize that um so we can see how we
can reconfigure if members would be
happy with that
um I'll be happy with that I don't know
it cancel Thomas do you want to comment
on that yeah just if you're increasing
the number of gas parking spaces by four
uh I didn't know how many accessible
places you have now but we need to
insist the increase is not not Remains
the Same just to get the four Park is
basically now I would like to see at
least one space out of the four as a an
additional accessibility space
okay it counts of bunting
yes thank you chairman I would have no
argument with one space out of the four
being argued I think I'll be a reason to
I think it's sometimes you do see if we
go overboard in this company like car
parks where everything stuff that
remembers this whole slew in front of
this shop but it's empty with Platform
One disabled car in the corner yeah and
you think massively overdone it there
haven't you but you know so one out of
the four I think will be a reasonable uh
proportionate response thank you
chairman
um let's just clarify the numbers
because I think I think there is one
there isn't there and I think what
members are saying is one one out of 17
spaces I think members are saying is is
not sufficient so it'd be
requiring the
school to develop that car park in a way
is to provide two accessible spaces
I think yeah we we could add the
condition we could say to increase the
level of accessible parking spaces and
then they might decide that they'll add
more than
you know it might be if we say to
increase
certainly we can say two but they might
provide three so we'll take that back to
them and say we want an increased uplift
of a minimum of one
uh so that we need to have a vote on
adding that to the conditions so at
least two members have spoken in favor
do
benchmarks against other schools what
they've got a similar size in terms of
accessible you know parking spaces so I
can think of I can think of where I'm
chair of Governors we have one
disability parking space in a car park
that's bigger than this they're at
Temple Mall
so I just wondered you know what you
know here we are we're debating here
about accessibility it's important but
you know are we benchmarking against
what's available elsewhere why are we
making an issue of this one particular
School
Okay so
I'll hear from Members I would ask you
not to repeat any points you may well
feel have a different view but we've
heard a number of views in favor of of
this proposal already and I'd like to
move to a vote on it as soon as we can
so I will come to uh councilor Thomas
councilor when Stanley and Council
Proctor and then we'll move to the vote
thank you
just in response to councilor Freeman
because it's important
thank you councilor Winston
yeah and not every school is influenced
in front of us for a planning
application only this is this is
important and we need to improve it
thank you
and cancel the Proctor thank you chair
one in ten adults are disabled
okay so it's been moved and seconded
that uh we we add or we amend the
conditions to require the school uh to
have uh at least I was saying an
increase on the current level of one
accessible space and then they can have
two three or many they're like that's
yeah okay so we're going to vote on that
proposal so all those in favor of that
proposal we could indicate no please
thank you
and all those against that proposal
so that is unanimous so we will
um factor that into the conditions and
we'll delegate authority to to come up
with a suitable condition
um
I think it's been moved and seconded
that we Grant permission about a number
of members have spoken in favor
um
councilor Thomas you spoke first and
they said you're happy to propose and
councilor Walsh I know you had some
concerns but you have in a second okay
so let's move in a second that we we
Grant planning permission as per the
officer recommendation
um so we'll vote on that now all those
in favor of granting planning permission
and all those against please
nice unanimous so that motion is carried
and planning permission is granted on
that application so thank you for your
contributions on that item we move on to
the last application now which is
application one zero eight eight seven
two uh the land burned by Elsinore Road
and skirt and Road in Stratford it
starts on page 140 and uh
um so um we'll start with an
introduction from Miss Coley thank you
thank you chair this application relates
to a 1.3 hectare roughly triangular site
at the junction of skirting Road and
Elsinore Road in stretford formerly
occupied by various industrial buildings
but now cleared
the character of the area is mixed
comprising residential commercial
transport office and Industrial uses the
site lies within the setting of two
designated Heritage assets Trafford Town
Hall grade 2 and the entrance portal and
lodges for the former White City
Greyhound track grade 2 and several
non-designated terrorist assets this
application seeks to vary the approved
plans under condition two of the
previous approval and also the approved
drainage scheme under condition 13 of
planning permission 100 270 which was
granted in May 2021 for the erection of
a residential development of 367 units
comprising five blocks of between six
and ten stories with Associated access
parking and Landscaping
the permission was subject to a section
106 agreement which related to
affordable housing provision and
education contribution funding of
parking surveys and and retention of a
design certifier the principal of the
housing development on the site has
therefore been established through that
recent Grant of Planning Commission
which remains Extant
proposed changes to the approved plans
were made primarily to an amendment to
the alignment of the access road and
some design changes to the elevations of
the blocks the drainage layout has also
been updated it is also proposed to
change the affordable housing tenure
from 37 on-site shared ownership units
to 37 on-site discounted Market rent
housing units two objections have been
received in relation to the proposed
change to the affordable housing tenure
and the proposed amendments to the
design these representations have been
duly noted and considered as part of the
appraisal the Heritage and Urban Design
manager has concluded that the
development would result in minor harm
to the setting of Old Trafford Bowling
Club negligible harm to the setting of
Trafford bar and Trafford Hall Hotel all
identified as non-designated Heritage
assets that level of harm identified is
unchanged for the original application
the TLC balance is engaged given the
council's lack of fiber housing land
Supply and when the Tilted balancing
exercise is carried out the benefits of
the scheme significantly outweigh any
harm which will derive
the application is therefore recommended
for approval subject to appropriate
conditions and a legal agreement thank
you
uh thank you Miss collider and no
speakers on this item so I'll see which
members of the committee wish to
contribute cancer akinola
[Music]
um yeah
and all this site really really well
because it borders on the uh Ward that I
live and represent
um I'm surprised I mean I look I mean
it's the first time I've seen him and um
I think I was on the planning committee
this time last year and I just think the
uh really oppressive and awful to look
at and so limited Green Space 10 stories
high some of them are going to be I know
this summer ground floor ones are going
to be townhouses
but 300 and well nearly 370 houses and
it looks like 10 of them are going to be
um available for social rent although
that will be
set at the market value I just think it
just depresses me to look at a scheme
like this and you're gonna funnel in
loads of families to live in these kind
of places and without very with very
limited green spaces that look
like
God Estates I remember as a kid whereas
don't look as rough as this is gonna
look
um
and that I know it's it's not about but
people I know we need housing I am
desperate for there to be more housing
it just feels like why is it Old
Trafford seems to get everything just
piled on top of each other rather than
just houses
that are one and two stories three
stories I like the rest of Old Trafford
used to be two and three stories just
all these blocks and I'm I know people
are sick of hearing me saying about
blocks but it's just depressing it
really is
thank you cancer Canelo any of the
members looking to speak on this item
councilor minutes
um I've got a question obviously in the
proposed compared to be approved the
proposal is slimmer so there's like a
whole loss is that right or have I have
seen that wrong if you just go there has
it got is it shrunk
it has very slightly in in one area
that's what there's there was a stepped
area which was being removed
fundamentally the scale of mussing is is
broadly the same across the development
because from there's another picture you
had this one wasn't sure the Another one
not that one sorry that one yeah is it
not is it not is it am I gay mad or is
it like has it has it is it proposed
yeah
back at the bottom is gone yes
so is that so it has a depth of the
building of the like say the
units inside it's lost
depth no yes yes it has a lot yes it has
lost steps so it's got smaller so the
dwellings inside it got smaller well the
dwellings inside have been reorganized a
bit as well so they are they are all
still compliant I'll get that they're
compliant but they've got smaller
yes the principle of residential
development on this site has been
has been set so we can't revisit whether
it's appropriate we we just have to look
at the design changes if I could offer
any reassurance to Castle Rock andola
This is the same architect that that
designed the corn Brook scheme which
members actually did quite like when
they went round
um on the outcomes tour and we think
this will be delivered to the same level
of quality so hopefully that offers some
reassurance
yeah I I just I I quite like the the
previous thing rather than what the you
know compared to look at the two but I
guess that's not what we're here
you might prefer it but
you need to identify whether if you
don't if you prefer it is it something
which would warrant a refuse and funding
permission
when looking at the scheme as a whole if
the old thing was there was something
already proved why are we now looking at
it again is that they brought it back
again seeing if they can this this is
not unusual to come come back with a
section 73 application for some
buildability improvements that that's
right that's that's what it is that is
the other one that was there is much
more difficult to because you need a
massive stale across it whereas if you
go straight up it's much easier to build
okay okay thank you Miss Kelly cancel
the bunting
chairman it's
a degree in many ways with anything that
councilor Canelo had to say and and in
many ways I thank you for your candor
unfortunately
it's all far too late
um
would that weren't the case but
unfortunately it is uh the decision has
already gone through I don't remember if
this was during my period And I wasn't
able to be on this community because of
the changes in times now have been
covered uh by councilor Rigby uh at the
time I don't remember this one but yes
it it sees a case of and again as
councilman this is the point it's not
even a case of do we prefer the new one
to the old one again for What Little
difference it makes I probably agree
with you with councilmanis on that one
but again irrelevant the point is is
there a planning reason why you should
refuse this I think they could go ahead
with the original one if they wanted to
even if we do approve it
so to help move things forward I'll
probably try and raise the spirit of
cancer graduates for those of you who
remember him and say it is with no
enthusiasm whatsoever that I propose
that we accept offers a recommendation
as unfortunately there is Naf or Choice
thank you chairman
thank you catch the Freeman
this is a variation and and it actually
you know whether you like it or not it
says it's too late
third time you've agreed with counselor
bunting this evening but uh
our chance of seeing a pig flying faster
anyway
uh councilor Walsh
thanks chair um
that's councilor bunting said take on
board what councilor akinola has said
but the changes are minor I think I
think the major issue to this evening is
is about the tenure and that there was
an opportunity for people to to purchase
houses on a shared basis I think and now
they're going to be social rent
properties
and I think councilor akinola said that
they would be at the market market
valuable social rent would be changed so
it'd be cheap it would be cheaper to
rent I'm
sorry
I'm
um do you want to say yeah thank you um
yes I can explain why that is um it's
because uh rather than to sell the units
um individually as as was they are going
to be sold as a as a lump effectively in
a forward sale as a as a rented scheme
and therefore
um the the affordable units will be
offered as a rent as will the rest of
the the development
thank you thank you
I think the important thing though is
that there's uh social housing is
available for people and that's what we
desperately need the housing market is a
strange thing prices just keep going up
and
um people are going to be renting a
suspect for a long time to come so I'll
be not happy chair but I'm I'll be
second in this application I think it's
already been proposed that we granted
I'll be supporting the officer
recommendation thank you councilwash uh
councilor Proctor
thank you chair
I too just want to look at the change
from shared ownership to affordable
housing it's not social housing it's a
80 of market value so
social housing is significantly less
I don't see apart from
it'll make them more money
[Music]
if they don't stick to the original plan
of having a proportion of them being
shared ownership it's a way of people
getting onto the housing bladder
when they can't afford
the full price of of a home and so to
Move It from that to affordable housing
at 80 of market rate doesn't seem right
thanks
uh I'll come to council I can owlette
next I suppose what I would just say on
that is
um
that that seemed counter-intuitive to me
but the report does talk about the
housing needs assessment and the demand
for affordable rented housing in in this
location rather than shared ownership so
uh so in my mind that's an improvement
it's obviously not as good as social
housing but that was never part of the
application I don't think um Council
rockinola I'll come to you
um it was just um two points really one
well aware that it was a variation and I
know it's an already done deal but I
wanted to make My Views known the other
bit was I just wanted to ask with the
bit about them selling it to as a block
um for
um affordable housing is there any
stipulation about I mean can they buy it
this year and sell it next year
does it stay as affordable rent for a
time set any limit yes yes the
affordable units would remain affordable
in in perpetuity
um so and a 106 agreement goes with the
land so if they were to sell the the
whole block uh well even if they sold it
individually which is not the intention
but but if you sell a whole block that
obligation goes with that sale and
whoever is then
um owns the land and manages the site
would also need to need to comply with
that
thank you that's uh any other members
looking to speak on this item councilor
Welton
thank you oh I mean I think everyone's
in agreement that it's that it's not a
you know a wonderful looking development
but I will we'll just um uh defend the
principle of high density identity
development in you know close to the
city center because you know
particularly as there is just across the
road there's another example of it which
is obviously dating from a from a
previous era so it's not that there
isn't isn't a precedent in the area and
if we're gonna
you know if we're going to deal with our
housing crisis without without covering
green space with with with lots and lots
of houses that have got Gardens and
things like that we're going to have to
build things like this and so you know
we I think we have to
um yeah we we basically don't have a
choice whether to to approve this really
because it's uh but I think the
principle of it is is is is good
okay thank you councilor Welton so it
has been moved and seconded that we uh
approve uh permission for this for this
development uh as profits a
recommendation so we'll move to the uh
vote on that
um
okay yeah sorry I cancel the sound you
did leave the room at the start of this
item so
um you won't be able to vote on this and
Fred cancel the talking you wanted to
I'm very very sorry to do this now
rather at the beginning but
um as I do sit on the investment
management board I am aware of some of
the background on this and I probably
shouldn't be voting on this
okay I think yeah
so I think that's probably a decision
for you I mean I don't I don't I'm not
familiar enough with the investment
management board but I think if yeah
that's that's your decision then fine
okay
um so uh councilor talk in uh I will not
be voting on this and Council Hassan
won't so for the rest of the members uh
all those in favor of granting Planet
permission if you could indicate no
please
okay
[Music]
that's unanimous so that application is
approved uh thank you members that
brings us to the end of the uh
applications for permission to develop
and uh just briefly conscious of the
time but we are not doing too uh too
badly so
um we'll just move on to see if there's
any urgent business
yeah
okay so there's no there's no urgent
business so that brings us to the end of
the agenda but if members could remain
behind once the meeting is closed to
please so uh with that we will um finish
the meeting and finish the broadcast
thank you
[Music]